but they're a beautiful big male this is
my first time what my second time seeing
him I saw him on foot this morning and
he's the new the new boy in the western
sections of of Juma and pushing ting
garner further to the east see where
he's off to he might hit off for a drink
it is nice and warm about 27 degrees
Celsius 80 Fahrenheit so not blistering
by any means but definitely warm Aki is
gonna lie down let's move a little bit
remember this is a hundred percent live
and what a wonderful way to start the
afternoon Safari so while I try get you
a better view of the movie let's go
across the meadow Makati well I can't
tell you how excited brent has been all
day long trying to find what he's been
bragging about it all morning how he's
going to get morning my name is Tanner
mccurdy and on camera with me is David
we've got some crazy squirrels going up
and down the street it's you figured I
come on I doubt it though because they
like to hide away but they're up in this
not for nerds black monkey orange and
there's some nice cavities so hopefully
they'll come back out again perfect
habitat for squirrels in fact and
they're quite entertaining at the moment
because when we do find them normally
they've got big marilla nuts running
around in their mouths stashing them
away in preparation for the dry times
that are ahead because winters on its
way how cool is that now if you haven't
joined us on a safari before it's good
to have you on board remember you can
chat to all of us you can hashtag safari
live on twitter or you can talk to us
via the YouTube chat I think I may be a
bit close to this tree they don't trust
us hey David I wouldn't trust me either
if I was an animal off we go so our
plans this afternoon are to try and find
should do which is a female liquid that
Steve had this morning on the Safari so
that's what we're gonna do we're gonna
have a little scrounge around and see if
we can pick up on where she's gone to we
have already checked Galago pan thing
and it's hot day she did have a meal
she's probably going to one to have a
drink
but sadly no luck what we will do though
is go down to the original spot where
she was and see if she's maybe just
somewhere around there right off you go
though - brain - already has a leopard
it's always very exciting to see a
leopard you've never seen before and
particularly a new male with all the
sort of dynamics that change and he is
really really beautiful he is very fat
and happy at the end and can see eyes
closed and he's lucky it's not too hot
today now of course I've been gone for
so long
I don't know too much about the hooker
Marie so if anyone's got some
information for me it was apparently
it's a Miss ID he's not from the hooker
Murray in Ottawa he could be from
somewhere else so if anyone's got some
information about the hooker Murray male
leopard for me I would love to have it
hashtag Safari eyes it would be great to
see if you guys know a bit of his
history and where he's from
and I nearly forgot to tell you I had oh
it's the boys from the borough on Drive
today so sends I owe myself for both
from the same small town were born in
the same small town in the kwazulu-natal
Midlands so nice to be back on the
vehicle with sense
and I said look like a kudu from what we
could see or kudu or big in yalla
difficult to say actually and there's a
tiny bit of meat up in the tree there
was nothing left now there's some more
on the ground but I think the majority
of the carcass was stolen by hyenas at
some point early this morning is that
the piece of meat
yes well spotted their sins there's a
piece of meat in the grass there
you can see how well his camouflage
works in the shade like that how those
rosettes break up his outline and make
them that's what makes them one of the
more difficult animals to find often but
here on Duma we are very lucky with the
amount of leopards we see now since I've
just seen how koumori and a workout
could be how many leopards I've seen on
a Juma in my time with Safari live now
of course the Queen
Garuda I heard two boys quarantine and
kanuma so I went was it true that
quarantine kanuma fula ting gana shadow
I'm not gonna count I suppose I should
account to the Cubs and and and and that
have died
no may be honest I can't the Cubs that's
a bit morbid so ones that have made it
to adulthood so a shadow and Salah Hesh
quoi Tila Ingrid dam which is now du
Loup and cheela
and that's ten obviously yeah
Sanne and Sangeeta
twelve tomba Tandy gajima keep going and
it must be more I don't have to wait
cause I was gonna take a while when I
won 16 already and I know I'm missing
quite a few we had some leopard
sightings and little just popped in and
out so while I try to figure that out
let's go back across to Steve to see
what his plans are for the afternoon
good afternoon a German I hope you all
having a wonderful morning or afternoon
wherever it is you may be welcome my
name is steve falcon rich i'm joined
again by mr sebah jambe on camera now we
are coming out thus often and we are
hoping to see if we can follow up on any
activity of those Buffalo from this
morning but while we're doing that we
also checking on the dams who knows what
might come in and out definitely on a
day like this it's warmed up a bit from
this morning we could have animal
movements as lots of elephant tracks
around so lucky that bread's has managed
to find the hukum woody again all the
hard work that the bush walk team put in
this morning is paying off and I'm sure
he told you to send your questions and
comments through the hashtag so far
alive and follow us on the YouTube
stream let us know what you'd like this
afternoon we're going to quickly check
the dams maybe some lions had decided to
follow those buffaloes in that could be
cool and then barring that we're gonna
go over to Chitra and see what's
happening that time so jump on board
fasten your seat belts get your popcorn
and snacks ready let's have a fantastic
afternoon Drive I'm super excited
Seb is on camera with me as I said in
his super excited he hasn't been with me
in a few days already said be missing
him so maybe it'll be a tie today that
horse Anna the little prince was a
little chief leopard decides to show
himself again because you all know
nothing how much she likes seven myself
and he hasn't had a cameo for a couple
of days I'm sure he is feeling a little
bit left out of the story with the
shadaloo female filling up the that the
air time for the last two three drives
yes yesterday morning yesterday evening
and this morning so she has definitely
taken some of her saunas air time and
they're giving Tandy a little bit of
respite so once we check treehouse dam
we're gonna zoom around across to our
eastern side and see what's happening in
it happening at buffalo and obviously on
the way see with us buffalo have gone
okay so while we go in search of the
water and these animals this go back to
brent Leo Smith and they're very very
dangerous looking hookah Murray
well here we go he's not looking too
dangerous at the moment is not facing us
it's just panting heavily and digesting
so oh it's lies it's about 27 different
leopards in my time at Juma
now of course that's not really counting
the ones from cheetah planes and chitwa
chitwa and and around us just purely
seen on Juma so quite a few not very
many places in the world can boast in
the world to you as 27 different adult
leopards and I didn't include a lot of
the Cubs that didn't make it to
adulthood so I think with those who
could be close to 30
Kathy is wondering has her camera
officially taken over Tinga on his
territory not all of it so I would say
how camera is doing almost exactly what
Kangana did many moons away many moons
ago he took over the western sections of
villas territory and then and then and
voila moved further to the east and
that's what's happening to turned on and
up
from what chatting to everyone here it
seems like he will go as far as sort of
quarantine maybe as far as the Marathi
but for the moment it tends to be on the
south western sections and and anton
ghana still holds most of the eastern
sections now of course that can change
and it all depends on condition of
Tenggara condition of a Komori it does
another new male come in so this is
quite an interesting time to be watching
the leopards here on Juma because there
is going to be a little bit of upheaval
now of course with her camera moving
into the western sections that has moved
Tandy and kab quite a lot further to the
east and spending quite a lot of time
and Torchwood and what buffle took and I
think what it all depends if if Tandy's
cab doesn't make it to adulthood she
will move right back into this area and
happily mate with her koumori and Jing
Ghana for that matter but up until that
sort of little leopard gets to 16 months
17 months oh maybe a little bit younger
as she's gonna try avoid her camera at
all costs oh it seems like school is up
is just turning around to try to find a
bit more comfortable spot because of the
heat but in the meantime it sounds like
Steve's search of the water horse is
paying off let's go see what's about to
go for a swim or drink
thanks brain sir we found this young
elephant pool very close to treehouse
Dam not drinking not doing anything too
close to the water but busy feeding be
quite selective of what he feeds on and
he is primarily picking very nice juicy
grasses that are growing off of that
termite man as he slowly disappears
behind it let's see if we can just move
a few meters forward get him on the
other side he thinks he can hide from us
trying to pull a hookah mori with the
termite mounds those of you have been
watching the show notice how Kumar who
koumori really enjoys we got a massive
there we go so what we do know I mean
who Kimura likes a too much man as he
likes to to find the war talk and get
them out of their burrows but what we do
know is the termites recycle all the
nutrients into the soil and so whatever
grows on a tumor man is generally got a
higher nutrient value then stuff growing
around it and you'll often find the
browsed vegetation on the termite mound
is always a little bit more then around
it because there's a few more nutrients
and elephants are smart enough to know
that not that it's that important this
time of year because there's nutrients
all over the place there is busy digging
in amongst what looks like a white
raisin one of the grievious species
digging in with his trunk
trying to pick whatever crosses might be
growing underneath he's gonna come
around respects there he is
beautiful very easy to see that it's a
young illiterate bull straight away
because you find him on his own you
wouldn't find a young female on her own
if you did it would be a bit unusual but
I've been trying to get him to turn to
see his right yeah because we saw a very
nice bull the other day with her idea
who is playing lots and lots of games
with us and still haven't seen his right
ear
he's trying to hide it from us but he's
not behaving the same way as that bull
that that bull was trumpeting and
running and being very sneaky yep and
that's the way it the cookie crumbles
and we have lost sight of this beautiful
elephant bull but no worry our search
continues
we house them there's not too much going
on so yes Jason Jason can't believe how
big they are
well Jason that's quite a small a small
guy actually to get twice as big as that
when you see a a proper elephant bull
one of the big Tuskers you are really
truly mind blown at the size of them I
mean they can get up to 6,000 kilograms
so that's about 13,000 pounds when I was
in the 1d national park a few years ago
they I'm having an aptitude hash of a
turn around here I do apologize I
reversed into a bush that had very sharp
spines in it and I'm you know steps my
good friend I don't want to injure him
but today hey Debbie and I was in the
one day National Park 2 years ago with
African parks they were doing some
translocations of the elephants there
Prince Harry was there and each elephant
that was picked up so their darts they
were moving it from luanda up to and
code to code so park for the north where
the poaching has decimated the the
elephant in the north and now African
parks is they're managing and really
really sorting out everything that's
going on so they were going to move 500
elephants in two years so they moved
about 280 something in the first year
and I was there during that period and I
was fortunate to be involved with the
removal of 9 the family herd of nine but
they were weighing every elephant that
went on because the crane that picked
the elephant up had a big scale on it
and the one elephant bull weighed six
thousand eight hundred kilograms that's
just incredible it's incredible size and
he wasn't even the biggest bull that
they'd seen in the reserve so I think a
lot of what we think of with regards
elephant weight is is a guess because
they did used to to cull elephants back
in the park in the Kruger back in the
day but I doubt they actually had the
mechanisms to weigh what those elephants
weighed it's possible they just
calculated what they got out of it at
the at the ever toir so to speak
but 6,800 is an enormous enormous
elephant kilograms so if you just times
that by 2.2 I think that is ridiculous
Beck says can you see the kuru over
there Ravinder wants to know but if
elephants have six layers of skin
Reuven dad don't know about six layers
and now they've got of an outer sort of
sort of the the the hide layer then
there's a lot of fatty muscle tissue
inside but I really have no idea the
number of layers I know that this
estimated to be about a hundred thousand
muscles in the elephant's trunk which
allows you to turn the trunk right left
up and hook up towards the mouth and
also that typical sort of trumpet lifts
up in front of it and also each of the
valves are able to work independently so
they can either trumpets or suck up
water we just losing sight of a little
of a female kudu they I think you know
is that a young male young male just
with the little horns and another one is
coming in from the back they're
absolutely fantastic how we can get kuru
in this environment and they are so
invisible the one that wasn't that
invisible was the one that hukum Orion
as hyena have decimated and Brent if you
were watching this morning offered me up
some liver which was awesome not really
but let's go back over to Brent at the
jokester and see what he's happening to
do with mr. CooCoo Murray
hey yes it was quite funny to try to get
Steve to eat some that I'm just moving
because he was look like he was about to
go up the tree but he's up there years
now he's not as relaxed as some of the
leopards we get here so he's by no means
unrelaxed but I just don't like moving
too much or too quickly around him I
think you might be going for a drink
Elizabeth is wondering how does Hawk
Marie's size compared to other dominant
males and now that I can see him up a
little bit and on the move easy he's a
good good sized male leopard you
probably a little bit smaller than 10
Ghana went in Ghana is at his prime but
often that doesn't mean anything cuz if
you look at him bulla bulla was actually
very small for a dominant male leopard
but often it's not the size of the cat
but the size of the fight in the cat and
as I said I think he's heading down to
have a drink so what I'm going to do I
just want to make sure where he's going
here he is he does have some meat
stashed down here as well and that was
the original meat we found as I said I
don't want to pressure him too much and
I say I don't know this leopard as well
as I know the other leopards so I'm
gonna give him a fair bit of distance
and respect I don't want him to become
as relaxed as ting Ghana and the other
other big males we get in this area so
we don't want to put too much pressure
on him so we're just keeping our
distance while he's moving when he lies
down or or whatnot then we'll stop a
fair distance away so I'm hoping he's
going to go climb up that fallen I think
it was a fallen nabh4 and if I remember
correctly where that's where I got
Steve's liver from this morning was
around here so this is what happens is
it looked like he caught the kudu
drinking at a pan
oh it's gonna be nice lights get ready
with your screenshots I found something
in the grass there I'm sure that as I
said is there's lots of bits of meat
spread out over quite a distance
isn't that beautiful and then afternoon
light now guide monkey says what asking
a question is it is it fair to say that
predator territories are more about sort
of avoiding or finding the the least
consultation for the best territory
rather than over resources um I would
say that play a part of it but I would
say a resource and female availability
is what drives predator territories as
specifically when it comes to to the big
cats so where you've got an area that's
resource rich you've got a lot of
females and a male leopard a male lion
they're sort of driving driving force is
to mate and make sure that their genes
get passed on easily so he's gonna go
ever drink let me just zoom around quick
you know that he's got some space so
this is actually where he killed the
kudu
and I'm going to try to get to the other
side looks like he's gonna go find a
shady spot to have a drink Oh hold on
we're nearly there
it's just have a quick safety shot from
here and let me just see there we go
that's when the trial go very slowly as
I said he's not quite as relaxed as mr.
t & Co all guys get ready this is going
to be gorgeous look at that face now
we've got a nice frontal view of him to
know she's wondering how do we identify
the different leopards now of course
when you spend a lot of time with them
you get to know them individually and
you can see body shapes size all that
type of stuff
but the best way with new leopards is
this spot pattern above the last line of
whiskers so you can see there that last
line of whiskers he's got three
prominent spots above it so each of
those each leopard has a spot pattern
that's like a fingerprint
well that nice scar oh he's got
character
and scar down and just below his left
eye
he's a thirsty boy his perfect spot
where he killed this so from what it
looked like is he actually cooked the
animal drinking and then dragged it away
from the water's edge and being a big
kudu it was too big for him to hoist and
then the hyenas made off with some
pieces of it he made off with other
pieces of it the little pieces he did
make off with he's managed to to hoist
into spots and I'm sure the hyenas are
still probably snoozing not too far away
hoping to try get whatever is left the
ultimate object opportunists monique's
wondering why would the hyena leave when
there's still food there well Monique
what I'm saying is that they haven't
left there will be while it's hot
they'll be doing the exact same as him
and you'll probably find behind is
actually made off with a fair fair
amount of the carcass from what we could
see from the tracks and they will be
some hyenas still in the area but they
also struggle with heat so they're
probably
is snoozing in the shade somewhere and
as it gets cooler they'll probably come
back for an expansion expect
inspection see if he's dropped some meat
or if he's abandoned some of the bones
that are too big for him to crash
the Dale's wondering will her cameras
julep get large as he gets older for
those of you don't know what a julep is
it's that little thick loose skin under
his neck now in methods it's there and
particularly in the male's it can be
quite pronounced and that thick blue
skin helps protect them when they're
fighting with other leopards now
probably it will get larger I'm not sure
how old he is and looking at looking at
him I would say and this is a complete
guest you guys are welcome to correct me
and just generally looking at him I'd
say he's about 7 6 or 7 years old maybe
even as old as 8 maybe a bit younger I'm
not sure I'd say it's 6 7 years old
I actually hear him lapping up the water
anything
and then one of the reasons I came here
at this time of the day he's probably
been snoozing for the majority of the
day there's a really good chance
especially as you get some heat starts
coming down just after three o'clock in
the afternoon and they might be coming
down for a drink and he has not
disappointed
oh he's heard something did I you know
oh I think there's a hyena I think
there's a hyena that's gone back towards
his food that's what's got him up and on
the movie all this big hole we don't
wanna fall into that we from the tracks
we saw yeah he absolutely gave those
hyenas as good as he got and I'll try to
show you that Cersei is heading back to
her words that meters I say I don't want
to spook him he should be about to
appear in front of us shortly
areas
okay
his body language change a little bit
maybe he just heard something and he was
just making sure that nothing was going
to try steal the remnants of his carcass
but when he goes flat again because of
owner these are running now oh it's a
battle ear a battle ear was stealing his
food it wasn't a hyena it was a bird
just took off as he ran towards the tree
again it's just
have a quick look yet as you might even
go up the tree to the battery I was
stealing that piece of meat from in the
tree and it looks like the battery I
might have knocked it down so let's see
if he lets just wait here a little bit
see what he does hey big boy oh he's
beautiful so there was some pieces of
meat in the tree and there were some on
the ground and it's likely that Vasilyev
might have dropped one of the pieces
onto the ground when it was disturbed by
the leopard running there I know Justin
told me to look at his tongue look at
his tongue it is so long silly looking
cat he might go back up the tree to
check we might just to flop down in the
shade there full up
okay well while he flops down I'm just
gonna wait a little bit to see what
happens next while we do that I know
madam mccurdy is searching for another
leopard about 3 to 4 kilometers away for
me we are we are we're not having much
luck though but we are getting closer to
solving the mystery and what we've been
doing now is we've basically gone
bubbles of boundary we've gone then down
the northern part of sandy patch where
Taylor access back up ovaries
we checked where she was no sign of her
all the way around now we've done
Gallagher and we've also done Gallagher
shortcuts but we haven't had any luck
and I haven't seen any tracks and where
we where she was sorry up in that marula
tree it's almost impossible to have seen
where she went and I did ask on the
radio he was the last person with her
and so I come down the tree and it was
yours fun buffle suck and he then
responded and said as soon as she
dropped to the floor he couldn't see
where she winked so we've been checking
around and around and around to see if
we can figure out where she's gone I
would
I would assume she's going to go and get
water some way so it's just trying to
find the pan that she's gonna drink at
maybe she's still in this block just to
the waste of us and to the north of us
pretty cool all right very quickly we're
gonna go across to Steve yeah thanks
very much Taylor we we're sitting here
with a group of little beauties and they
keep moving off so Seb has been trying
very hard to keep catching up with them
and there is another bird on the left
the trees well called the ground scraper
thrush one of the nicest birds archer
and we've seen him quite regularly
lately and very characteristic black
stripe on the face sort of through the
eye from the eyebrow and a very streaky
chest very easy to identify thrushes
versus robin chats which frequent very
similar sort of habitats is if on the
ground you see a bird of that sort of
size if it runs with its head down and
it stands up tall it's generally a
thrush if it hops around the same sort
of size is probably a Robin jet so that
is something you can do to help you
identify them in the undergrowth if you
don't get the colors very well you'll
know at least which family to go to
Robin chat or thrush and here is the
ground scraper very pretty bird
bee-eaters are all over the place yeah
in the open feeding on at the back over
there they are just up and down and
service finding it very difficult to
find them there he goes another one the
bee eaters like to catch insects on the
wing and there we go right to the screen
said it's gone marvellous he's landed
exactly back there again their practice
of behavior known as Hawking where they
fly from one perch and I grab an insect
on the wing and then they will land back
on the same branch and often use that
branch itself to smash the insects on
the branch if it's a bee help to remove
the sting or if it is some form of hard
shelled insect use the branch to sort of
break the carapace
open so that the juices can go inside
and get eaten yes joy bee-eaters are so
so pretty we're very blessed to have
quite a few species down here always
enjoy showing the beat it's probably one
of the prettiest families out there and
this is the littlest and the most sort
of I think overlooked we do see they
don't normally come in such large
numbers they are here all year round so
we noticed when the Europeans arrived
sometimes when the Carmine's arrive
they're very sort of noticeable and the
beats has been quite small seem to just
slip the notice of most people Heather
you want to know which park we're we're
in we're in Juma private night reserve
in the sabi sands greater Kruger
National Park on this sort of
northeastern side of South Africa I hope
that helps the sabi sands is
world-renowned for game viewing and for
leopards as you've seen with the Kamui
so we are now on our eastern boundary
with tortured we're going to drive up
the road keeping our eyes peeled for any
tracks of tündi and also trying to see
where these buffalo might have gotten to
on our way up to zero I would like to
know how far apart the guides are from
each other
that's I will show you on our fantastic
map that Gerry provided she works in
production here we are over here at the
moment we're about here on our eastern
boundary and where is Brent is over
there so how far is that so probably
about two and a half to three kilometres
and Taylor has been working up in this
section over here I'm not sure exactly
where she is now but this is where we
had the shadaloo female this morning and
so she's checked this whole area now not
sure where she's going to go to so we're
on the complete eastern boundary over
here we're gonna go all the way up here
see if there's any activity of Tandy and
their cub coming in while not we're in
the area and also the Buffalo are
probably in this area so we'll see if we
can find them they haven't come to Twin
dams or treehouse it's possible they
might have gone up to above a sock Dam
and what we do know about the Buffalo is
that the lion prides in the area they
like
to follow the Buffalo and also that
young man that little chief leopard or
sauna when he smells a buffalo he likes
to follow them as squat and who is with
Scott and walk the other day was a Jew
said I think it might have been Dave saw
his day for never animals run in charge
it's always Dave but Scott and Dave are
on foot and they heard the Buffalo
Stampede and they thought it was the
Lions chasing them but it was the little
prince
the little chief hasana a two-year-old
male leopard who's got the most
character in the world and he was all
sis last seen in this sort of area so
who knows where and what we might find
and remember folks everything is
absolutely live coming to in real time
from Juma okay so we're gonna go back
over to Brenton with the new and
established Rainer of Juma let's go back
to Brendon he's looking quite
comfortable in the grass over there so I
said I wanted to show you some tracks a
little bit early I said I think that's
what we're gonna do while he's flat cat
in the grass making sure the battle ears
don't come back to steal his meat let's
go have a quick look at these incredible
tracks so that's how we knew something
was up when we arrived when we found his
tracks walking in from the South from
outside of Juma so he came in last night
or early this morning and we saw the
tracks going down the road and then we
followed them towards the pan and then
suddenly we saw where he had been
fighting with hyenas and that's when we
knew something was up so there's an
incredible spot where he's moved the mud
that's been sprayed around by some
elephants and you can see that he is
gripping into leap2a to chase the hyenas
and it's just done yet
now this pan always brings back lots of
memories for me I had some in credible
sightings with Hassan and shangilia in
the rain yeah playing and jumping up and
down all over the trees we're probably
about 70 or 80 meters away from him now
and I'm just trying to find this track
again it was so clear this morning but
now that it's dried out a bit it's not
not quite as care in the harsh afternoon
lights but so what what looked like
happened in action is to see you can
actually have a look at but I think
happened is he stopped here for a rest
and you can see where the grass is a
little bit flattened right next to us
yeah so I think he was lying there and
while he was lying here the poor
unsuspecting kudu came down for a drink
now he's a little bit wider there since
to the left of tiny birds to the other
left so he was there behind that log and
the coot who came down on the opposite
side of that green grass to drink and
from what we could work out he lept
across and grabbed it around we're just
beyond where that elephant dung is there
there we go and then from that little
corner there of the water where the coot
who was drinking he dragged it off to
the right to that thicket here we go and
he drags it into that thicket there and
then that's where the hyenas found him
yeah unfortunately the track is not as
clear and I can't really see where it is
it was so clear when we were on foot but
it's one of those things
now all the little pieces of liver
including the one I tried to feed Steve
this morning are all gone
they I'm sure the bachelors and Tony
eagles and other well predatory birds
and scavenging birds came and cleaned up
that crime scene now of course when we
were there it was still quite early and
a lot of those birds had not found it
yet so that's why we were able to see
all the little bits of blood and and all
sorts that were around
my god let's go back to the leopard
so he found his tracks coming in it from
that side down this road well hi Walt
Walt would like to know what happens to
a male leopard who uses his territory
well while it becomes a very difficult
time for that male leopard so male
leopards when they become independent
from mom and get pushed out of the area
by their the dominant males in the area
become nomadic and the same thing
happens at the end of a male leopards
life when he has pushed out of his
territory again they will become nomadic
and they tend to sort of try slip
between different male leopard other
male leopards territories a little bit
of long grass there but not too bad so
they'll slip between different male
leopards territories and try avoid
conflict at all at all costs they still
will try and Rob a lot of kills from
females and other young males so they do
move around a lot more than when they're
territorial males and territorial males
do move around a lot but what they're
doing is moving around and and and scent
marking and patrolling to make sure
there are no other threats coming into
their territory oh yeah that's nice of
them to lift his head
and belly full of kuru now flushing with
water after that big drink he's a very
very tired kitty at the moment very
happy cat as well well are we gonna say
chair a little bit longer I'd like to go
to some of the water holes to see if
there's any elephants around but in the
meantime let's go see how Steve's doing
somewhere else out there in the African
bush Thank You Brent we are doing
fantastically well it is a lovely
afternoon to be on Safari
after the cool conditions of this
morning it is a glorious afternoon
hello ladybird you want to know forget
Robins like the Robin we get in Europe
the red-breasted Robin called the Robin
in Europe let me show you quickly in my
very nice book over here
how many Robins we in fact have we have
got many many many Robins just give me a
moment it's not my book I'm navigating
apologize for the delay no that is the
wrong page sorry folks
see that's why I'd like to use my phone
the phone is far easier to use the phone
app give me just a moment so there are
lots of Robins and lots of Robin chats
as well and if I just type in here Robin
okay
scrub Robins Robin chats have a look at
the bird family see here we've got lots
of the scrub Robins I'm not sure if the
color is very good on the screen air
here we get bearded Robin beer describe
Robin brown scrub Robin so these all
kind of Bush felt
open grassland sort of savannah
specialists and they are all very very
camouflaged and if I go to the next page
hang on there we go here we get the more
colorful a sort of more woodland forest
type birds the white broad Robin chat
the white throat scrub chat kappa robin
chat and then the red capture oven chat
over here which is very very pretty and
then over here are some very special
ones which you find mainly in forests
and areas i haven't even seen yet up in
the top the white starred Robin very
very spot forest specialist I've never
seen the swenerton Robin I think that
somewhere else in in Africa and then
that is it for our Robins but I know in
Europe even Europeans have only got the
one Robin and have very very territorial
and if you like to see them and you are
in the in Europe they would respond very
very well to that behavior I was doing
the other day then shh-shh-shh
they come and they get quite sort of
territorial ah who's that who's in my
spot and it's awesome to see
I really enjoyed birding in the UK the
birds are very responsive to alarm calls
especially in the oak forests up there
Rob would like to look for some sunbirds
Rob I'd love to show you a sunbed I
don't know why we don't see that many I
mean for example the the white-bellied
sunbird is normally a very common bird
in other places I've worked as well as
the Mariko sunward around our camp we
get them they are there I don't know why
on drives I haven't been seen them but I
will look for a Sun bird for you the red
breasted or the the scarlet breasted sun
bird is also very very beautiful haven't
seen one here um I will make a very good
effort to find you some Sun birds but on
the topic of birds look at the feather I
found only moments before on the road
look at that this is the feather of a
lilac breasted roller and you see that
the colors are they are made up of
carotenoids and melanin and of the Blues
the dark blues is something they called
Tyndall scattering so essentially this
sort of air pockets within the the
feather cells and they reflect the light
in a certain way to give it that
beautiful color there's no actual
pigment it has carotenoids and melanin
and melanin makes it nice and strong the
Afrikaans word for a roller is called a
probe bunt and for those of you who
don't speak Afrikaans throw means to
Mary and a bunt is a band so essentially
by giving this to someone you are
committing yourself you could
essentially say would you marry me with
this feather and it is very very common
in culture African culture as well and
chief lobbing gula who was a head of the
in the Bailey's one of the tribes that
you find in Zimbabwe
he banned any warrior to wear any
feathers of the lilac Priscilla this was
his bird and if anybody was caught
wearing feathers of the lolly Priscilla
yep he was quite an interesting fella he
was a very very big man and very very
wealthy because he had a lot of his sort
of his his guys in the mining sections
of Africa at the time the gold and the
Diamonds the diamonds and Kimberley and
what he liked to do is a lot of his sort
of
his his people who worked in the the the
the big pit the Kimberly diamond mind
where the Cullinan diamond comes from
just by the way it was given by Cecil
John Rhodes to to the Queen and she
still has that in the crown jewels but
he used to like to cover himself in
honey and stick the diamonds to his body
because he had many many diamonds
brought back to him from the mines from
his people and he likes to cover himself
in honey and stick them on me
until one day Cecil John Rhodes did him
a very bad did him a very bad deed and
ended up taking Zimbabwe from him by
force back in the day it's quite an
interesting history Rhodesia it was
caught eventually Robin once know if
guinea fowl are related to Partridge I
am Not sure I mean what is the the genus
hmm there's a partridge a gala form
because I think galliformes all our
Franklin's we get share and I think the
guinea fowl also falls into sort of the
family or order of galliformes so if a
partridge does fall into that then yes
they would be related but I honestly
don't know a lot about partridges apart
from the fact that they occur in a pear
tree
here's that right am I getting my my
Christmas song is mixed up thanks pecks
you said I am correct okay so yesterday
there was someone who's very interested
in finding a mongoose trap and I don't
know said if you can get it just over my
shoulder there it's not very clear
there's some bird tracks let me jump out
and circle it someone yesterday wanted
to see a mongoose track here we go
actually I'm mistaken now that I look at
it it is a squirrel but here we have the
squirrel toast one two three four five
in a pair and he has the back foot toes
nails
who's going picture so not a mongoose my
apologies I did look at it very briefly
I wonder who it was I'm forgetting his
face someone wanted to see a mongoose
track always on the lookout for little
tricks like that maybe it will be better
on the bushwalk okay so tail is out
tracking as well let's go over to her
and see what updates she has for you
well we're checking one last pan of
water and then we're done trying to find
a leopard for part of the afternoon oh
we've checked a variety of different
places where I thought we'd find all
sorts of creatures and the only thing
that we have seen is afternoon will
Johnny have the long list of animals
we've seen and birds in the beginning we
saw receive the water was that the first
animal or chunk also did not want to be
on camera
twice we gave it to opportunities kept
running away we moved on we have seen
two yellow-billed hornbills fly across
the road and one Impala Ram I like a
herd of Impala and they won in parlor
and that is the extent of our animal
sightings this afternoon they're a
little bit on the quiet side but I do
find that this sort of northwestern
corner can be a little bit quiet
other than the Impala hanging around you
don't normally see much so I think once
we've checked this other pan just off
we're Taylor access we're gonna go look
for perhaps some elephants and I think I
think we'll go up towards buckles with
dam and we have a look around there
maybe we'll even papa Sydney's things
like that just see if we can see any
elephants in in the distance but but
it's okay we'll get there we've also
seen quite a few snake tracks so I've
been singing a snake song and I can't
remember the words to it cuz I made it
up numb but hopefully we're gonna see a
puff adder
here's Phoenix you're wondering if
there's any honey badgers
yes there are any ventures they're just
very shy and the best time to see them
is actually early morning late evenings
as the Sun has gone down and here's a
watering hole Oh little Terrapin gone in
the murky waters
so so yeah so they do occur I haven't
seen honeybadger for ages though we
often just see their footprints
unfortunate with the tall grass it makes
it difficult what we got from the water
today I can see little ripples here and
there one of their little boatman or
just riders skidding across the water
definitely some little midges or flies
or sorters or black specks that you can
see on the top of the water
we are the swimming ones it's not really
a smooth surface it's kind of like when
you go ice-skating I'll say this like
I'm a professional I've been ice skating
on a whole whole of whites but you can
see when the ice gets sort of quite cut
up and it's not as smooth to skater out
on I wonder if the water Striders and
boatmen and things like that struggle to
move around when all that algae forms if
it's not as easy for them just get
across but a bit difficult to see I
noticed most of these little pans also
getting all this alguna to see the water
scorpions anyone know they're like that
though the water scorpions will enjoy
that anything that ambushes as a hunting
technique let's check those next little
pan nice watch a nice patrulla trees big
boar beans for liquids to sit up in see
bubbling who's making the bubbles lots
of bubbles however they could also just
be me thank deaths pushing up if there's
any vegetation that is well supposed
decomposing it'll give them quite a bit
of that only there's an effort can pygmy
hippopotamus in this puddle no there's a
little Terrapin here though oh yeah
there we go who's that
you see that someone's skimming across
the water amazing well we'll also
continue to keep checking these muddy
wallows for animals I think the
elephants will be heading to them
Steve however is looking at some more
tracks yes I am thank you and I've found
for you the track I was looking for not
the exact track but we have got a track
of a rather large Mongoose and I'm going
to point it out to you if you can't see
it here are the toes
two three four and there's the back pad
that is the one foot and here's the
other foot I would assume this is the
back and that is the front and it is not
walking on what we call justify so it's
not standing on mongooses don't do
that's not that cats and where the toes
have pushed forward because the claws
you could see the scuff in the sand and
this is the track of a white-tailed
Mongoose probably the largest mongoose
we find in the area and i heard someone
talking there about honey badgers we
found tracks of honey badgers a few days
ago but what's very very interesting
about the whitetail mongoose is if you
have a look at the picture itself you
can see the whitetail and you can see
the legs are black the body is black
underneath now when the white cell
mongoose is threatened by a predator
what often will do is it'll crouch down
low will bend the tail over its back
onto its neck and actually mimic a honey
badger because as we know archer honey
badgers are very very scary and have
lots and lots of sort of what's the
words
lots of now full of beans should I say
and so an animal see the water mom who's
pretending to be a honey badger and so
go home hang on hang on hang on this is
not exactly how I'd like to pull out my
evening and then leave it alone and the
white among who's gets up gets away with
it
so isn't that marvelous so the track we
can measure it from there to there
that's about five and a half centimetres
long and beautiful to be able to see
these things the marvelous thing about
tracking is that you can see animals
that are in the area that you don't
actually see so the honey badger we got
Rex aardvark we got Rex well I tell
Mongoose we put checks we don't see them
but it's a passive way of knowing that
animals are in the area so a very nice
way of understanding what we have and a
good way of identifying animals and
areas to clear areas like this put some
form of food down or bait station and
you can actually have animal tracks
coming through and you can develop an
addict it's not a liquid butter a
species count of animals that you might
find in the area that are very very
seldom seen for example hiking in Table
Mountain I have found tracks of a
leopard never seen a little day but I
found tracks which is really always very
very cool to know that you're walking in
an area where you find dangerous cats
and the hikers in front
I didn't even see them so that's what I
love about trekking you can always see
what is around even though you don't see
it okay so the arts of tracking is a
wonderful science let's go over to Brent
Leo Smith and see what his views are on
the matter well how come where he is
very flat at the moment and well Stevie
and Channing are tracking and the fact
that he saw leopard tracks on Table
Mountain I've seen their tracks in the
Kirsten Bush National Gardens on Table
Mountain as well so they are leopards
around those cape mounds and leopards
however have incredibly massive home
ranges in comparison to 11 yeah male
leopard in the cederberg or in in those
cape mountains can have a territory of
up to two hundred thousand hectares so
that is for sabi sands and that's due to
lack of prey availability and it also
causes them to be a lot smaller and much
much smaller he's probably 80 kilograms
and a male leopard in that in the
cederberg and all them in the cape
mountains is probably only 35 to 40
kilograms so 50% in the weight and
that's all to do with food availability
now my favorite thing I think about
tracking I don't know there's something
I mean to be honest he's spotted
something how you know coming in no and
he's put his head back down again you
just jump popped his head up for a
second there but yeah everything about
tracking I just love being out on foot I
loved having close encounters with big
cats with elephants with with Rhino
Buffalo and it is quite exhilarating I
just just absolutely adored now one
other thing Steve was chatting about
Robins a bit earlier now for those of
you in the Europe and UK the closest
Robin to what you call robin redbreast
or whatnot
to bring up my big book because that in
terms of looks of course is a forest
robbing there's quite a few different
color variations of forest Robbins I've
been lucky enough seeing quite a lot of
them and I've seen them in Gabon I've
seen them in Congo so there we go the
forest Robbins is probably the closest
in terms of looks to the UK over robin
redbreast oh he's down again
he's just getting hot and moving around
so that may occur pretty much in the
northern congo basin forests if we have
a look at their distribution map they're
so very very cool now I'm trying to
decide now whether to move along or sit
with her camera a bit longer so why
don't you guys just make it easy for me
and decide for me so ash tags fire dive
should we stay or should we go up to you
I don't think he's gonna get after too
much but it is just incredibly pleasant
to sit next to a mess of male leopard
he's it's always lovely to see them
especially through the grass sometimes
some of my favorite views are leopards
are not way out in the open it's sort of
views like that where you've got the
grass in front of him and so just a
leopard in its habitat a big boy
sheshank is wondering is there any
difference between Jaguars and leopards
yes quite a few they're indeed a
separate species so that means they
cannot mate and produce viable offspring
and Oh flop Jaguars is physically much
bigger than a leopard and often going
over 100 kilos where a male leopard of
100 kilos is is almost unheard of
they're also far more aquatic than
leopards leopards will swim if they have
to but they don't really like getting
their feet wet weather as Jaguars will
hunt and swim and lion water to cool off
so of course they have what you call
sort of parallel evolution there's a
they have evolved on the other side of
the world literally and the the dappled
markings and spots for camouflage is a
parallel a parallel evolution there are
parts there are both part of the Pantera
family so the big cat family so they're
both able to raw but yes yeah so there's
quite a lot of big differences between
them it's tired kitty
sorry Bix could you go again with that
question that game drive radio is quite
loud
hi TV TV is wondering to what extent two
other lodges share information on
leopard sightings well it all depends on
your Traverse if the lodges traverse
over the same area there's extensive
information shared there's actually
whatsapp groups and that all the guides
in the sabi sands are part of so if a
leopard that no one knows arrives you
pop a picture on there and see if anyone
else knows that leopard so we do share
information extensively with the other
lodges of course the lodges that you
traverse in in the same area you share
more more information with because you
out there in the same places every day
now for example when we share a lot of
information with Chitra and with Timur
of course now of course it's it's for me
it's quite easy with Chitra as well
because if we don't get any information
I'll give my brother a good cup around
the ears as my brother is a guy dad - -
Ajit well
ah now apart from sitting with leopards
one of my favorite things is to spend
time with our feathered creatures and it
seems like Steve is on a birding mission
this afternoon thanks Brent yes we have
found ourselves a little indigo bird
ladies and gentlemen and it is with a
laughing dove Oh off you went
now when you want to identify these
birds Indigo birds you need to have a
look at the beak as well as the feet
because there are three indigo bird
species that you could find here could
be the dusky the purple and the village
now that individual being the male he
had what I thought was a white beak you
still got him there's some starlings and
buffalo weavers around he had a white
beak and orange feet so that was the
dusky indigo bird which I don't actually
see very often
the dusky inga bird I can show you on
the the phone here if you didn't get a
proper look let me just get you a nice
photo of him there he is
how's that look
oh sorry about the reflection folks not
working very well today
there is the red beak the black beak and
the orange feet so very important to
identify that and the Indigo birds are
also brood parasites and we just
double-check who his African fire finch
so they will lay the eggs in the nest of
another bird and these below the - let
me try that all down Bex let me try put
this in the shade there there we go
that's better
apart from my head you see he's got the
white beak and the orange feet and so
there will be brood parasites of African
fire finch and I haven't seen many fire
finches in this area I haven't actually
seen any this is my first indigo bird
this season and so it's quite awesome so
the females are very very sort of
cryptic he colored the male stand after
that very very bright sort of it
actually looks quite blue in the right
light but he looks like black or melanin
and stands out CD - they're all here at
this little pen here drinking in
there are CDs as they need to sorry
about my gear hello infernal you'd like
to know what go away birds are hmm I've
just found some lipid tracks underneath
my vehicle which is this is the last
area sips is that we had to tündi so
we'll have to make a little bit of a of
a show see which way she was going you'd
like to know what an indigo ed bird is a
go away bird is a they used to be a a
taco or a lorry let me show you it seems
to be very nice birding afternoon we'll
get our borrows on in our bird books go
away okay doesn't want to show me where
is the go away bird in here go I'll find
him gray go away bird there it is now
hopefully this is going to be a little
bit better but easier on the screen now
come on come on screen there we go there
yes he is great and he's a square and
they used to be part of the luery family
but now all the louise have changed to
tacos and i'll show you why i go to the
bird family if you have a look at this
page here have a look at how all the
birds on this page have got a red a blue
and possibly even green in their pigment
whereas the go a bird they on the right
is very bland with nothing to show for
himself except for gray feathers and now
all of the other ones have got a red
which is called tea resan which is a
pigment they produce and the green is
called Taraka verdun which is also the
only green pigment found in nature and
so all the Leary's have now been called
two rockers because of that double
Terris interior covered in' sort of
headline and the grey go a bird now
matches his counterparts in northern
africa
so that is why hits call ago a bird I
hope that answers your question very
very common in this area but I'm going
to pop off for a few moments to try and
make head or tail or what's going on
with these tracks because I'm not sure
if you want to go to someone else while
I do that
okay we will link to Brent because we
have got tracts of the cub here as well
okay so we'll come back to you shortly
let's go to Brent
hello welcome back oh it sounds like
Steve's a gone off the feather Domitian
and on to a kitty cat mission I hope he
has success there I'm just sort of man
during down towards the tree house water
halt hoping that there might be an
elephant all three about I didn't hear
any while we're sitting with nakamori
but they might be moving into this area
in the Ferno is saying if different
species do not make how do you explain
hybrids hybrids are very very rare in
the wild so what happens with most
hybrids it's people that cause them so a
very very cruel practice and that has
happened a lot
not so much in Africa but particularly
in in North America is the hybridization
of big cats so forcing a lion and a
tiger to mate what that is they keep
those animals in close contact for
extended periods I mean those animals
fight beat each other often die in that
the quest for a liger or I forgotten
what the other one is but it is a very
it's very cruel and barbaric practice so
there are very very few hybrids and in
in the mammals in the wild and they tend
to keep to themselves although a couple
of years ago there's a very very very
interesting hybrid that happened in the
Linea ante area of Botswana which was a
hybrid between a Ledge where and a water
back so it does happen but it is
incredibly rare and a lot of hybrids as
I said I said are generally done by by
people and trying to think of some other
obvious hybrids a donkey a zebra and a
donkey again humans putting them in
close close close proximity so it's it's
it's it's it's generally human beings
that cause hybrids now in in in nature
hybrids can happen and actually quite
quite common in Birds of more sorry this
game Drive radios going mad at the
moment so it happens quite often in
birds and then the hybrids were probably
there from a very very close family very
close closely related family actually
show you a hybrid quickly
I mean just get on some flat ground so I
don't torture sensor while he's trying
to level the camera okay there we go
some some flat ground here so I'm gonna
turn this off you know making an
incredible amount of noise talking about
very little everyone saying hello so
certain species of hybridized quite
frequently one of them is the little
seed eaters so often there they start
I'm just there you go so wax balls are
known to high five inches sorry are
known to hybridize and which means that
a lot of them are probably very very
closely related and it's it happened in
the very sort of recent times that
they've split there's still a lot of
research being done into hybrids and
birds but as I said in in mammals what
are you complaining about
bird never look like it could be a snake
there so it's very rare
so most hybrids in the modern era are
forced by human beings and some
absolutely barbaric practice what we use
squawking about Lila crested red and
yeah lovely late afternoon light on the
roller so the rail is was squawking and
there's also a Franklin squawking in the
little river system just to be on the
roller so I'm gonna go see if there is a
snake or some other form of predator
maybe even a predatory bird around while
we do that let's go see Taylor who's
with some animals that are enjoying an
afternoon swim they are they look so
relaxed these hippos almost too relaxed
in fact they've barely got their heads
above the water this afternoon but soon
we have arrived at before look down just
to have a quick squeeze and to see if
there's anything around and we haven't
got too much on chair but we do have two
hippos which is quite nice and like I
said
just just relaxing going about their day
know thrashing in the water just yet I
was hoping that we were going to see
them open up their mouths and show their
big teeth it's always very impressive
when a hippo does that because most of
the time we just seen a little bits of a
hippo and this is the typical sighting
that you have I can tell you most of my
guests have in fact only seen this part
of a hippopotamus ahead ears the eyes
and of course the nostrils and that's
about it and we're lucky was spoiled to
check to Adam almost every morning every
afternoon we see them playing around
those little ones are so playful now
there's lots of different things that
live in these dams not just big hippos
but from lots of different species of
birds and Terrapins and well-child of
the universe you were asking if there
are any frogs yes of course there'll be
some frogs and we probably have a better
chance of finding them a little bit
later tonight so that's something that
I'm always up for finding is is them for
being species they're one of my favorite
in fact so maybe we'll head on towards
twin dance or not - not twin dance
actually you know it's a good one is
treehouse down it's a particularly good
one Oh an apparently world frog day is
in two days time now some of you may
remember last year's hilarious and
phibian antics we all put on remember
David I was sleeping and snoring I was
pretending obviously I wasn't really see
if I don't actually sleep like that
stiff did some great frog noises are
really terrible who else was making frog
noises someone went ribbit ribbit can
you believe it I feel like it may have
been Rebecca that actually did that it
was an eggs either did it you know we
all made noises eggs EI k Zonda all
making strange noises I wonder what
we're going to do us yeah who knows and
and then there are some little birdies
David can I point you in the direction
of so you see within the middle of the
dam at the other side where the grass is
quite close just to the left of it
there's like a little V that goes in
there some little three-banded clubbers
there's just 2 3 bad and clubbers
they're not three three-banded clubbers
very busy this afternoon as there always
are working very very hard moving those
legs pretty quickly looking for insects
on the surface and on a hot day like
today I think that they would have
filled their crops up quite easily with
all sorts of little insects oh no they
may have been actually analyzed I think
they may have been three III band of
brothers in fact now we're when are you
wondering if there any shrimp or prawns
in the water
well I remember last year after a bouts
of rain the mud wallows had filled up we
did in fact to find some freshwater
shrimp I think they were called fairy
shrimp they're bright red in colour I
don't have a picture of one but I'm
pretty sure someone can put up a screen
shot for you because we were all so
fascinated about it so yes they could
possibly be in here too and would be a
very important food source to a lot of
critters that live in the water so I'm
on bush walk in the morning I think
we'll be checking and aim sort of having
a closer inspection of the mud wallows
I'd like to do that on my bush walks and
see if we can find some water scorpions
because we're finding some exoskeletons
of water scorpions and we'll look for
frogs or even just some frog tracks
might be quite nice to look at and
anything else that really wants to show
itself member we'll try find those fairy
shrimp again the only problem is and
we'll check more
algal bloom that we sort of see in the
water tomorrow when we can get close to
it and it's like I said earlier it's
great if you're an ambush predator and
you're thinking murky waters nothing
we'll see you camp but it makes it hard
for us to spot things and there too it's
not great for us so now that we've
checked bubbles of dam I think we're
gonna take a drive along worried pan
Road and perhaps check worried pan well
we might remind you hippo pools do that
now some maybe and the three seniors
that live in the water and childhood
universe you're wondering of it there
are wondering sorry if there are some
that are perhaps becoming endangered
well there's quite a few frogs that live
in specific areas or very small areas
there the Western leopard tone is one of
them that unfortunately is under threat
at the moment and that's because and
habitat loss a lot of them cross the
road so they're being killed pollution
into freshwater systems again frogs are
super sensitive and really good
indicators to the environment
I might have sort of how clean water is
and so that's one of them then these I'm
just trying to remember all the frogs
and you see is that the Amur I'm a
toilet toad is it it's in hogs back I'm
just new I'll bring my frog book under
ah that's another one only occurs in a
small section of the Eastern Cape again
habitat loss is a huge factor when well
sorry
Rebecca's saying all sorts of things
make me laugh what distracted me I'm
trying to be professional and educate
people here Rebecca
Rebecca's directing today so see ya so I
will have a look at a couple but like I
said the main factor to a lot of the
reason why species are going extinct is
due to habitat loss unfortunately
because of us because of us as humans
raking the environment what's making
that noise can you hear that
I don't know let's be oh you know what
it is you might be able to see it it's
doves fluttering in the leaves behind us
so that's what was making it feels
really strange son anyways we're gonna
kick it towards quarry pants a little
productive pad maybe we find something
there Steve however is got some
elephants and I'm sure you want to find
out more about those unable to cover
tracks yes thanks to that we've managed
to find this big elephant bull
apologises decided to go behind us
instead of in front of us which was the
plan all along we did have a long chat
before you came on air about him going
in front but he is decided to defy me
but this is this is the African bush and
the elephant will do what he likes so
the tracks of that female and cub it's
handy and cub came from grower pen
directly into the block towards us here
so we're just taking cheetah cut line to
see if there's anything crossing but
this is a very very large block and if
step just pans across even if we found
tracks what a difficult area it is to
look for a leopard in this block even
yesterday Brent was driving around
aimlessly trying to just hopefully bump
something so you know we're gonna move
on a little bit further from here see if
anything cuts across here into the east
so far there's nothing but we will keep
you updated if we manage to find
anything very fresh it seemed to be like
Tandy and her cub had drunk their bag
wari pan and they're come directly into
the block maybe she's got a kill if she
does could be anywhere in the section so
maybe I'll chat with her be maybe he's
keen to to bring tail into this area
tomorrow on their bush walk to to put
some effort into the tracking of her cuz
now if Scottie D gone he seems to be the
master behind finding Tandy but then
again
ladies gentlemen mr. Tristan Dix is back
on Drive tomorrow afternoon so if anyone
can find Tandy it is him so I'm excited
to have him back I saw his cars already
in camp so looking forward to a little
catch up with him this afternoon and see
how his leave has been and fill him in
on the gossip and the scoop
of the Leopards in drama of late so
while we up here if we don't get any
tracks we're gonna still have a little
look at before silk dam and see what's
going on okay well we gonna go over to
Brent
it looks like he's cooked his goose well
here we go
well we've got goose and something else
is that a cause Ling or is it something
else entirely and let's go across to the
ones to the left oh there we go those
three there and zoom in on the one in
the middle I know you Oh
stretchy stretchy no I wonder if you can
tell me what those ah hashtags fire live
if you know what that is that is not the
Egyptian goose it is a very very pretty
duck the males are far more striking
than the females and there's a all
females there no males presently at
turned ABS doing a bit of prepping and
preening and feather cleaning
now these particular that's can actually
travel incredible distances and at this
time of the year they move around all
you got some Cape total Bev's in the
background as well so they'll move
incredible distances between different
water halls and they really like
seasonal pans and the Ducks and that's
all the clues I'm giving you
promises they're doing duck yoga yes
indeed
actually what they're doing is they're
they're cleaning a lot of their feathers
and sort of when they're preen like that
they want them to be in the perfect spot
and some of the feathers for flying but
often when they're doing their chests
and stuff like that it's their swimming
feathers to get make sure they've got
that lovely little sort of waterproof
waxy layering in the correct I'm trying
to think corrector spots so that they
don't take on too much water and go down
isn't that wonderful now we've got a few
more birds up on the other side yeah I
was going to move forward a little bit
see if I can give you view of them again
it's disappeared as lovely as the dam is
for bird-watching one of my favorite
spots to birdwatch
is around a seasonal pan like this so
you can see there lots of nice grass so
this place is for the creeks to hide oh
there's a woodland Kingfisher you see
him since
there we go and there's a safari vehicle
in the background there's some elephants
that seem to be heading in our direction
and I'm hoping they're head towards the
water here so I'll move when they get a
bit closer but I was hoping to see some
cracks and that Kingfisher looking for a
frog or something in the little pan
below more could just be really to dive
down there for a drink
okay let's get into a position in case
those elephants decide to go much
barfing and wallowing there's a whole
host of little pans in this area down
here hold on you know it's only taking
there's a big bump there that
no little cracks neck
Oh quickly across to Steve yes with a
very pretty little steer look and this
one has been very obliging and standing
very still normally once they've been
detected they disappeared very quickly
into the undergrowth be very alert for
tündi and a cub in this area see her
nostrils are flaring up see what is that
a bird every bit of a fraud says said
look at those ears focus and she just
said pretty good eye flies all over her
face come on my dear blinky get rid of
the Flies she doesn't want to move folks
she doesn't want to be feel as if she's
been seen by us now she's moved very
delicate aren't they there's a fully
grown animal I've only ever seen one
baby Steinbach with busy suckling and
was so cute and so small I've never seen
another one though look at that face
absolutely gorgeous
that very small mouth to last four very
selective feeding you Heather Swenson
spur fowl making all sorts of noises in
the background and you see him said
there we go there's the Saran cents per
foul male you can tell it's a male by
the spurs on the back of the feet on the
back of the leg which they used for
fighting
it's a typical of a male to perch on a
little bit of a ledge and do that very
sort of smoker's cough sort of sound
that you heard isn't he pretty
t-bird he knows it I wonder if the
ladies think the same
give us another call my friend I might
try and play it for you so you can hear
it again I don't know if you all heard
it it back home it's turning out to be
an absolutely marvelous day for birds
and you didn't hear it soon as said
moved off of him
yeah now you heard it okay so there's no
need for me to play it now how marvelous
is that hey as we moved off a little bit
camera shy before and as we moved off
you played the call thank you my friend
you enjoy your your perch okay well
let's go over to Brent who has got a
crossing oh yes it is a crossing a
crossing of elephants nice but you heard
now they've crossed into into Juma and I
thought they might stop at baboon pan
but it looks like there might go all the
way to in dams we're just sticking with
them now doesn't look like they've been
here having no splashing and playing in
the mud yet today but they're much
definitely do it in twin dams yeah let's
let's move quickly
min-jeong I write good bags okay guys
let's keep up with these elephants now
and then like go straight into twin dams
by the looks of things so I'm gonna suit
around this way so we are not going to
affect them or impede them and it can
possibly oh but quickly for the birders
keep everyone happy
look at that beautiful Hoopoe sitting in
the gorgeous golden light and elephants
behind the big end of the small hey hold
on you're all the own sins and okay
let's do this we they coming up onto the
twin dams wall now
Oh bouncy bounce
I hope they get their water walk on to
one of my favorite things when elephants
get the water walk they get excited when
they get close to the water and they
know they're gonna go for a swim Wars or
a drink and we're now in the perfect
spot directly opposite them you happy
yeah Oh magic and I was really hoping
for some lovely Ellie Ellie action
around the water halls today and I'm
being sported a hooker Marie elephants
elephants elephants look at that little
one it doesn't want to get too close to
the water it's quite steep the bank
don't fall in
he's decided that place is too steep
that's too steep for me there I'm not
going down there it's scary now what I
think will happen is the eighties will
some of them will drink there whether
it's steeper but the majority oh I've
seen this female throw that one there
the big female on that on the left look
at oh she's she's I've seen her before
but a long time ago and I haven't seen
often she's got a missing half of her
left ear and she looks a bit but strange
you see that it's got almost no left ear
and it doesn't look like it was cut or
anything like that looks like it's a
natural birth deformity amazing isn't it
hello dawn and Dawn is wondering at what
age do elephants start to grow tusks
well they have baby tusks and for the
first year of their life and then at a
year old they start growing their big
tusks off there's an even smaller baby
an even younger baby than the one we're
looking at earlier I know little one
tiny tiny
there hasn't been too hot today so
ladies might not sort of dive in so to
speak and go swimming and they might
have a drink I was hoping they might do
a bit of mud bathing as I said okay
comes Oh bully now you happy about this
slippery slide ease deep slope what is
going on yeah oh look at that all the
adults camera and comfort Oh sham peace
oh and try again here we go yeah oh dear
a couple of weeks old that one he
doesn't like Oh for the no no pick it
out so I think what'll happen is is that
the little ones not so happy the herd
might move around towards the the head
the head walk head of the dam where
there's a it's not as steep
as it it's been quite cold today so they
might actually just move off and
continue feeding we'll see now it was
that is that was a very cute little
elephant he did not look happy with that
steep slippery slope at all almost like
I've fallen down something like this
before
I don't want to do it again hey I'm NASA
music our little because they're gonna
disappear behind us that looks like
they're gonna continue on towards that
mawashi riverbed and to feed and I think
I'm gonna keep up with them for a little
bit longer
trim buds is do I think animals notice
deformities and others I'm sure but I
think it really depends on the deformity
and if it is a deformity that weakens in
animals particularly if it's a male
who's going to be fighting for for for
mating rights I think in then yes other
animals might take advantage of that but
with elephants you see quite a lot of
different deformities with Ellie's lack
of tails ears all sorts of things and
there the elephant's seem to not take
too much notice of deformities and
others now if we're lucky there might go
have some fun in the sand in the
material bed dust it all around and I'm
hoping they do that because there's some
really nice Eddie's in this hair there's
some youngsters that are very playful at
the moment there's that tiny little
gorgeous creature
now they split the other little one went
off oh dear no it doesn't look like
they're going to do that I love it girl
yes I see you it's okay it looks like
they're gonna cross straight through the
Marathi and up and start feeding on the
bank on the other side well oh there we
go down the steep hill oh I always love
it when that happens
it's sort of the sheer weight causes
them to speed up as they go down well it
doesn't look like they're gonna hang
around for too long so I mean send you
across to Taylor who's got lonely
elephant we do know that's not English
it looks like a young bull and he's
actually been very accommodating this
afternoon he has moved a hole of about a
meter in ten minutes I would say maybe
not quite ten minutes maybe about in
between six and eight minutes and the
time does fly when you're out in the
bush and I don't know if there's any
little marilla's that he's perhaps
picking up because I can't see him
pulling any leaves and things out and
there is a smaller tree above him so
perhaps he's lucky and he's managed to
find the
last of the fruits underneath all those
round leaf teak and large fruit or bush
willows looks like he's being quite
picky about what he goes for you know
dropping some of the vegetation on of
his mouth concrete you see what he is
getting in fact there we go that well
that's obviously leaves and he was
eating yep
stripping them away and he's just taking
it easy it doesn't look like he's been
for a swim recently I think he must have
gone one for one midday midday swim
during the heat because he is a lot
darker than the color that elephant
normally is although I suppose it
depends on what soil they cover
themselves with and and that would
determine the color of the elephant he
looks a little bit on the down side but
all on his own unlike that herd of
elephants at green tad so he's been
kicked out now living a life of solitary
swatting that tail keeping away all the
biting flies I even have a quarry branch
in the car today the insects have been
particularly bad be nice if he gave that
my ruler a shake just to see if they
aren't one or two more fruits still
dangling on holding on maybe they don't
want to leave either
hmm no no child of the universe you said
why our young elephant pools not lonely
when they go off on their own because
they essentially spend well the
beginning of their life and I heard I
think they just get used to it it's a
very very traumatic experience for these
elephants to get pushed out of the herd
I've seen it a couple of times and it's
it's never quiet nice because
essentially what happens is that they're
inside heard many the the older cars
sort of stand their ground and what they
did once in the Eastern Cape they formed
a wall and every time this young bull
would try and come back into the herd
there the girls are basically just chase
him away and chase and chase and chase
and then they would go back and he would
still follow the herd around but that
gap would get bigger and bigger and
bigger and the cars would be less and
less tolerant of them so I think it's a
very traumatic experience for them and
but it's just one of the things that
happen so it I'm sure it takes a bit of
time to get used to and they do meet up
with other young bulls along the way
though if they find them and they can
tolerate one another these Bulls also
form bachelor hoods and it's typically
when they get into the prime of their
life anywhere between about 30 and 40
years old and you know that's been a you
really start to see the true size of an
elephant and they they then become lone
Wanderers and go off and start searching
for breeding herds looking for cars that
are coming into Easter I think on the go
but it is quite nice in the southern
Kruger you see spectacular bachelor
herds of elephants lots of them in
Zambia too big 50 60 70 of them all just
marching across the plains big ones
small ones medium-sized ones it's quite
cool and a young girl like this egg
would probably benefit from moving
around with a couple of other old
elephant bulls sort of learning the way
of life also been put into their place
and they can be they're probably the
most cheeky at this age otherwise when
they're in maths they will so pretty
cheeky too we're very calm kourin eyes
is very peaceful sighting he's not in a
rush she's not perturbed by us at all he
hasn't even acknowledged that way ya
know he can hear us you can smell us he
can see us
but he hasn't showed
any interest whatsoever this is quite
nice
it's always nice when you can just sit
from a distance and watch the animals as
they go along now
I did go past quarry pan and I saw the
tracks that Steve had so we're gonna
also have a little look around here no
no Steve said he was heading to Chitra
so we'll carry on exploring around this
area and see if we can't pick up on
anything now he isn't stopped feeding
since we've been sitting here a
combination of swatting those starting
the tail around and flapping the ears
and eating pretty good at multitasking
and cool now you're wondering how much
does an elephant need to eat in the day
well I suppose it depends on how big
they are
so essentially an elephant needs to eat
about 5% of their body rate body weight
sorry that's just roughly and at the
amount so depending on the size of the
elephant would determine but I mean a
fully grown elephant bull can eat
anywhere between 150 and 200 kilograms
of vegetation a day so they're very busy
and they will feed for about 19 hours of
that day so very very small amount of
time is actually safe for a sometimes
elephants can go 24 hours 48 hours
without even having a siesta they'll
just go go go and the reason why they
have to eat so much is firstly because
they're enormous they're the largest
land mammal and they have a really poor
digestive system so it's you know
they're only digesting one is about 44
percent of their food every day this is
why when you find elephant dung you can
almost tell immediately what that
elephant had been eating 24 hours ago or
so you can find undigested fruit we find
a lot of undigested marilla's although
they can't peel back the skin and pull
the flesh off of the seeds so they sort
of just crunch it and and get all the
juice from the fruit
you see twigs you see whole leaves
sometimes bits of bark that's quite cool
in fact when you find elephant dung and
to do a bit of digging to see what what
they were craving that day
mmm-hmm now take you've asked why do
elephants sometimes rock one leg back
and forth when standing or you often see
elephants doing that and also crossing
their legs I suppose that just maybe
resting them and I mean that we normally
do that rocking motion with a leg I
don't do it for too long but you do see
them sort of standing cross-linked just
getting the weight of why supposin maybe
you get a bit tired too so they can do
that
remember elephants don't sit down very
often or lay down should I say be quite
funny to see a elephant sitting on its
bottom normally you see that when they
go down to the water and like you saw
with brains sometimes slide down the
bank then you have to sit back and well
enjoy the ride and with all the
elephants of course they don't do that
as well as often but in the Mara
actually saw quite a few elephants fast
asleep big ones - snoring away which was
quite nice to see was like the little
ones just standing by going I'm not
ready to sleep it off you guys know
Richard sure you've asked cuz you know I
use this weirdest words I think thanks
to my Australian parents and we're
wondering what is a squiz because I used
it earlier a squiz I don't know where it
comes from I don't even know if it's a
word but it's a word that my parents use
all the time that can look a quick look
we're gonna have a squiz at the spider
building it's wave we're gonna have a
yeah I don't know David do you know what
I'm talking about a quick look a quick
look
that's what exquisite so yes
Rebekah's is like a peak having a peak
of something it's exactly right I'm not
going sidling like I said I should see
across to Steve because it sounded weird
we're gonna go down the spy break
however and see if we can find Tandy
maybe she's on the move now that it's
cooled down a little bit let's go see if
Steve is on his way to church worth
yes thanks very much Taylor we've also
been doing having a bit of a squiz
around to see if maybe tündi and a
couple just pop out of this big block
very hard to see anything inside so
seems like Taylor and I are in a very
similar area but we're gonna be moving
out of the areas soon
one final squiz as you'd say to see if
we can see her what's that said said
another cool bird we're having a
wonderful Sunday afternoon of birding
and let me just try and find what it is
said it was a cuckoo it looked like
either a Jacobin or love Ellen's cuckoo
I didn't see the colors very well the
levan it's got white black lines on the
white chest and the Jacobin just says
the white chest easy to remember cuz the
valence has a w-4 lines whereas Jacobin
doesn't have any lines in it he's enough
they're a black bird the watch is the
last crest and the top quite a long tail
and they will probably be departing soon
as the breeding starts to slow down so
Jacobin but I haven't heard them calling
in the last of the while which means
that they're probably not laying their
eggs in the nests of other birds at the
moment anymore
they're just feeding and their primary
source of food most the cuckoos that
come down here are caterpillars I
apologize for any of the breakup we are
just going through a little rough patch
I'll just travel a bit slowly we're
gonna be coming out of this area soon
and if there's no sign or further sign
of tündi and company then we're gonna go
and try our hand at chitwa and who knows
if we will be lucky maybe with 10 Ghana
I believe he was seen the small I
haven't seen that old Dylann sometime
him
there's been windows that I see him it's
been ages actually last time I saw him I
was on foot actually added for it for
you tell the dad okay
sorry about the signal folks we're going
to quickly go over to branch who I'm
sure he's got far better signal than we
do and we catch up with you soon
welcome back well unfortunately Steve's
heading into a girl named Lindsay I'm
back on the new road wonders I wrote
that I drove for the first time
yesterday I think it's possible that
that should do Lou female might have
come this way you never know but my plan
is just check through here it's quite
nice driving a new a new road and then
as it gets a bit cooler I might head
back to see Hawkeye Maury I see almost
sounds like some Japanese samurai water
there's nothing he's a samurai here we
go since I says he's therefore near
Samurai
oh come on it's such a beautiful oh
hello new it's so beautiful at this time
of the day you know lone wildebeest a
bull looking for girlfriends of course
the bull breeze right in the sabi sands
is about to start
quite soon so that's always fascinating
to watch the the different males and
their different strategies to keeping
females within their territory
so what I think he's doing he's moving
from that open-air around the big brown
ivory tree and he's gonna head to go
Park offered pilot planes see if there
any girls there it's just such lovely
lights at this time of the day oh you
might go to knob for an open or narrow
Sousa as well and it's not too far away
Oh what gave you a fright something gave
him a fright I don't think it was a
leopard I was okay I was always hoping
that everybody's gonna start snorting it
was probably a Franklin in the grass
that often happens with quite a few
different ones yeah he's carried on in
the straight same direction
no I can't see anything let's just keep
moving and have a quick look never know
any tracks yet no no tracks as this is a
really lovely area and this road is is a
very well-placed road and shadow used to
spend a lot of time in this block and
there were no roads yeah and it often
took us quite a lot of walking in here
to find her and now we've got a nice
road where we can see tracks now for an
update on shadow attracted to some of
the era these guys they think she's
actually down in Hoffman's near the Mala
Mala boundary and especially with hooker
Murray being in this area she's gonna
try avoid this area if not Barbara's
still alive all right and that is what
she'll be doing keeping a very low
profile so be interesting to see what
the should do do female a gets up to
whether she's going to try and take a
chunk of Candy's territory in this sort
of northwestern sections of Juma now of
course that could change very quickly
so if she loses Tandy loses the cub
she'll move straight back into these
areas that hooker Marie's in at the
moment
but while hooker Marie's around she's
gonna spend a lot more time that way and
that's given the shadaloo female a sort
of chance to come scope out this area
so actually next to the the camera ops
logging station in in in the final
control there's a list of names of the
Leopards so the cameramen don't spell it
wrong and I was having a quick look at
it last night after after drive while I
was chatting to Nicola and and it was
amazing that how many leopards have how
many leopards have actually moved on to
greener pastures in the last couple of
years so since I was just gonna you know
see his hand come through in the little
bit she's gonna come wipe his lens so
well below we're not a hundred percent
Sean but it I mean he's he's an old man
he's on his way but out of that list of
of leopards so they were quite a few on
there that have better that have died it
was a salah' Hesh gorilla and I mean to
really long-standing prominent female
leopards in the area quite chilly I'm
trying to think of arsim they're just
looking at that list of Atami shangilia
we can't be 100% sure on but I would say
it's it's probably highly likely that
that that she got killed just because of
the density of other territorial female
leopards in the area and it really
breaks my heart to say that because she
was definitely one of my one of my
favorites so I mean she would normally
have popped up somewhere by now someone
would have seen it because in the Kruger
Park so the east of us is there is a
concession where there's there are
safari lodges as well and I think by now
we would have seen a picture of where
somewhere in the same goes for the
manatee
now just there's dominant female
leopards in the menu lady very close to
the sabi sands border so there's not
it's not a good place for her to go
there and it's very good leopard country
that Southern Man Yeti so
there's plenty of females up that side I
said I took bit sad but it is what it is
I'm trying to think what else well I
can't remember now but it was it was
quite a shock to me you know I realized
how many of those those leopards work
were passed on to happy hunting-grounds
I mean a skedaddle past the gara Peter
shortly this is one of our repeaters
that brings you the picture together you
might be sitting in the world and it's a
very prominent one you know in this pop
around the corner and you'll get a nice
view of the gallery repite it is okay so
our signal from the vehicle goes to go
to a pizza then it goes down from that
there you go there's the antenna Oh
what bad squab Robin such a lovely call
and then it goes down to via teller or
to final control and then from front
final control out to the top of my lip
scope Mountain I think I might be wrong
tech team is welcome to tell me if I'm
wrong and then then I don't know where
it goes but it gets to you and that's
what's important
ah there we go Thank You Conrad I am
correct so I actually think if I
remember correctly I haven't heard this
before it goes to by next or London is
London it goes to next London next guy
Lana he's 10 years old he'll Eric I
would like to know do Valle de B's
travel in family groups like elephants
do now not really they have a slightly
different sort of set up so May of all
the beasts in this area so in different
parts of Africa they have different
strategies in this area the Melville the
Beast will defend a territory and the
females will move with their babies
between different males territories so
so the females will travel with the
youngsters and the males will stay in
one sort of spot so we're gonna head
towards and put on a compiler plane
shortly and that will see it could be
another loan Melville to be looking for
girlfriends over there now in the Mara
that wildebeest migrate and the males
migrate with the herds so a different
system so you could say that the Kenyan
and Tanzanian wildebeest they travel in
family groups and the males will travel
with the herd at all times and they
don't they don't defend a set territory
now that's of course because it's a
different eco system but here in the low
Falls of South Africa the males do not
travel with the family groups
now Steve is on a proper birding mission
today so let's see how his search is
going yes indeed Thank You Brent sorry
folks you've been having some signal
issues so you haven't been able to come
to us and so now we are stationary
hopefully things will work out but we
have managed to find the bird that we
spoke about earlier someone asked what
does it go away bird look like in here
we have two beautiful beautiful birds
look at the crest on the head and notice
how they are completely gray hence the
name a gray go away bird and they are a
woodland specialist we find them all
over the low felt all over the savanna
and they absolutely love seeds and fruit
and small leaves the new shoots of
leaves and buds and even flowers and
they will be here all year round nesting
and quite communal sort of nests on top
of trees marvelous I'm so glad we were
able to find one
and indeed Brent we're having a
fantastic afternoon with birds and I'm
not sure if I can start moving because
if I do we might lose our signal
Beks what do you think can I start
moving or should I stay stationary we're
going to attempt it we're gonna go very
slowly and hopefully our signal issues
are not going to continue we are now
slowly making our way towards chitwa we
have not managed to find any more signs
of that beautiful lepidus sandy and her
cub so I think me being able to see that
cub again I'm going to have to really
earn it really really earn it
but I'm up for the challenge
everything seems to be okay in my ear
eastern sides fantastic we're on the
eastern side on a road called
drakensberg okay well as we think things
are working things don't so let's go
over to tail and see what updates yes
for you sorry everybody gremlins are
attacking as steve is using the wrong
way punishment punishment later in
campus right so we're just bumbling
along at the moment and we're looking
for more tracks of that leopard because
they just fake having a little look
around things giving alarm calls but
does anything that sounded didn't sound
terrified little bit scared but maybe it
was a raptor of sorts so I'm just
checking very carefully wrong quarry
quarry oh no oh no oh the scenes is Oh
Steven are just me bouncing back and
forth today the gremlins are both trying
to get us off you go back to Steve the
gremlins and leprechauns whatever it
might be I am not sure what is happening
this afternoon we are now stationary Seb
has just been in the boot trying to
fiddle with any wires and see if maybe
something's been dislodged nothing so
okay so when we probably cut away we
might do a reboot and see if we can by
powering down powering up again the
system will kick back in we don't know
but seeing as we are stationary and
we're not moving anywhere for the moment
just to show you where we are we are
down here on the road called drakensberg
because on a beautiful day if we go to
the right hand side you can often see
the Drakensberg in the distance but on a
day like this we cannot see it but it is
a beautiful Vista nonetheless just a bit
of cloud and moisture nepo spheres
making it very hard to see you can
see a little bit of it just over there
Seb it started to come through now the
longer we look at it there is the mass
there is the Drakensberg in the
background and that is one of the masks
that provides us with signal so very
strange that we're not able to get any
that drakensberg mountain and on top of
that is what we call the high felts
everything east of that we call the low
felt low felt meaning low-lying Range
lands and high felt meaning high lying
Range lands the difference between the
two areas would be altitude and that
would lead to frost the difference in
frost will lead to difference in
structure so down on the low felt we get
no frost that's why we get more trees
and the high felt only trees that are
very well adapted to frost will grow
they're normally in your ravines and
that sort of thing but very very open
grasslands in a huge proportion of the
high felt okay so I am going to dare to
try and move because we would like to
get down to chatter eventually so Bex
I'm going to start moving and I am sorry
if we lose signal but we are on a
mission so it seems the best thing to do
is to go to someone who's got signal
let's go over to Brent who seems to be
in a very stable place as well we're
very close to the guy with a repeater
that we just had a look at so we've just
popped out onto Impala plans and I think
that wildebeest we saw obviously this is
one of his patches in his territory
because there's no Valda beast here at
the moment yeah but as I said I'm in a
loop here along the western sections see
if she dudu pops off somewhere she was
in that general area and then I'm gonna
sort of slowly loop back towards my
movie as we get closer towards the
evening Senzo come on
okay cook Acosta Taylor who's got some
swine so we've got some piggies at
Quarry van well they moved away from the
pan because of us unfortunately so what
we're doing now is you're just sitting
very quietly I'm not gonna move the
vehicle at all and we want to see how
desperate they are for a drink Inga's if
there are desperate enough they should
just come back and it will require
beautiful to see them having a drink of
water and perhaps even wallowing in the
mud
Sunday afternoon jacuzzi tongue come on
pigs yours didn't run away so I know you
want to come back here just do it we're
like they're not scared of us Oh was it
would have carried on and opted straight
into the bushes but they're lingering
so let's see if there's going to be one
brave one it's basically it's it's a
patience game and this is also where the
last of the tracks are for Tandy and
that little one who knows maybe Tony's
going to pop out the bushes and try and
catch one of these these peas but
somebody else has joined us and the
watering hole it's just behind some
grass at the moment it was like a turtle
dove on its way for a drink it's not too
frightened of us come on war talks if
the Dove is not frightened of us then
you surely you've got nothing to be
worried about well you can see it's not
a red-eyed death because it doesn't have
a red eye but even even the turtle dove
a little bit nervous to come down not
because of us I think because of all
sorts of critters that lurk below those
more murky waters always a quick drink
hey in and out well it's just resting on
little pitch yeah is the other one I was
gonna say it's a bit strange but there
aren't two of them you don't often get
to see just one turtle dove on its own
are you gonna be brave enough to come
down as well they're beautiful birds
especially that golden right on them all
the different types of grays and sort of
tones of brown and of course the
prominent black markings but a bird
that's often overlooked I am being very
careful
well it's quiet maybe they've seen
something else oh look there's even a
little wax ball to the left Davi that
have come down to drink look at this
yeah a little boot party and laughing
dough but that's beautiful that wax ball
blue X ball popping on two feet coming
down to have a quick drink there was
another one to wait
also not staying around for too long
laughing dive coming in all very
cautious I wonder if those are knocked
Andes tracks they're sort of below the
birds feet it looks like there's some
footprints in the mud and they look
fairly fresh too from this angle come on
have a drink get it over and done with
this very nervous this one no uncertain
as to what's going on who's going to try
and surprise it and we were talking
about this yesterday as birds and
various mammal species are exceptionally
vulnerable when they are taking a drink
because they're focusing of course on
getting as much water as possible no
pigs of this appear Davi that didn't
work okay well it was quite nice to see
all sorts of things coming down for a
drink my pigs will let them come back
now
Tippett you're wondering if the warthogs
can squeal yes very loudly they squeal
they were making a weird sound just now
I'm trying do it no no I don't know how
to make it but it was like a a rumble
it's a funny noise that warthogs do and
they kind of do it when they're a little
bit nervous because they do with the
expression they lift their heads up a
little bit as if they're trying trying
to see better and that was quite funny
that they do they make all sorts of
noises that they grunt and they squeal
normally you only hear a warthog
squealing when leopards got its claws
and rattle a hyena or lion or anything
like that then you typically hear them
squeal not this area is a favorite area
of candy so we're just going to check
very carefully she loves drakensberg
Roach and of central she loves all these
and it's nice and lots of impart around
you lots of different vegetation for the
animals to feed on so that will bring
them on in oh that's actually very
pretty yeah I'm going to very quickly
show you one thing because that's so
stunning I know Steve are showing you
the Drakensberg but that is a magical
view one of the higher points here on
Juma lovely perfect evening I think
we're gonna have a great sunset but off
you go to brain she's got his second
really good eighty sighting well we
thought I've spotted an elephant who's
got a Fang like tusks but it's not as
big as oh not as pronounced is Fang but
she's disappeared that's not her they're
just crossing the open area and they're
now disappeared into some quite thick
quarry thickets unfortunately Oh anyway
we've had such lovely elephant sightings
that staff noon so this is what it is
they want to go eat in the thickets
they're more than welcome to
they might pop up on the other side so
I'm just gonna go around
oh good question from Rick Rick is
wondering what the elephant teeth looked
like well apart from the tusks of course
such are quite visible an elephant has a
sort of a really big solid tooth and
with lots of little grooves in it and I
don't know how to describe what an
elephant tooth looks like which I think
about this for a second I think Rick the
best way to figure out what an elephant
tooth looks like is a Google elephant
teeth I don't know how to describe it
but our big males elephant the truth can
be sort of about that long and and then
depending on the where from feeding it's
got grooves and lighter and darker
darker patches I've actually got some
fossilized elephant teeth at home and I
found in zululand also got a piece of
fossilized elephant tusks and I found in
there in the low Falls okay I got a
feeling they're gonna pop out here and
the light should be
ah well Thank You Kayla mccurdy who is
sending me a picture of an elephant
tooth to my phone that is very kind of
you Taylor
I hope she remembers to use my South
African number not my Kenyan number
because I am NOT going to get the one on
the Kenyan number oh yeah no it doesn't
look like I thought there might the
frontrunners of the herd might be ready
to pop out yeah and looks like they've
stopped in the center too Munchie
Munchie Munchie yes there's in the fact
they're coming out ed yeah well you win
some you lose some
Oh wonderful it seems like it's an
pachyderm filled afternoon so let's go
across to Steve he's got some Whaley's
this youngsters a little bit too old to
be suckling but it seems as if mum is
pregnant so it's possible that of
mammary glands are producing milk again
for the new new baby that's probably on
its way she's right next to us
quite relaxed I apologize for the aerial
as SIB turns the car they've been
walking straight towards us Anna just
walking past us now the 4-toed ronger is
following them picking up on any insects
that the elephants flash from the grass
isn't that marvelous we are at Chitra
now just above the dam currently and we
found ourselves elephant how marvellous
is that they are more in the distance we
can hear said can apparently see them I
haven't managed to see them so we're
gonna come around good answers damn
see if we can get another look
I might even just try to get another
look at this elephant yet
she is very pretty very pretty mama very
very pretty she's tolerating that
youngster suckling but if she does give
birth to a baby she'll have to prevent
that one from suckling because he is a
bit old now to be nursed mmm Hotel dron
go for Sir John go has annoyed that
little boy we can tell it's a little boy
hello here he comes
hello isn't he precious isn't he
precious Oh shake your head young sir
isn't that fantastic that just made my
day and just like that the naughty
little elephant all retreats back into
the vegetation where Mama's are gone
isn't that fantastic I love elephants I
love it when they behave like that and
show us their the the humorous side okay
well thank you for that performance I'm
sure a lot of the viewers back home
would have enjoyed that as much as I did
okay let's go down to the dam have a
little look at some hippos see if
there's elephant to wherever they are in
the distance are going to materialize
what is that okay well we gonna go over
to Taylor who's got a picture I think
she's being a dentist today let's go see
what she's going to talk about what
dentist I'm trying to find the picture
now here's my sub close one we're gonna
have a look at my screens not too dirty
least we're not on the Sun haha oh hang
on you know we can do David I was gonna
turn the light up but it's okay there we
go there are the elephant's molars so
you can kind of see that diamond shape
in there which is where the Latin name
locks it onto Africana comes from it
describes the diamond shape and their
teeth so you can see it and basically
the older ones are here on on the side
so this is where the end of the drawer
is and then this is the back of the jaw
on the right hand side of the phone so
they push up from the right hand side
and move forward like a conveyor belt
and you can see the car worn that one is
on the far left you see how there's sort
of no grooves whatsoever so that's just
natural deterioration from feeding on
all sorts of things and then I'm gonna
show you another one and just need to
find it there we go that's the one I
want wants to go that way sorry David
there we go so this is an elephant skull
that unfortunately died and puffles hook
and you can see these there's all the
teeth so this is the top jaw that we're
looking at this is the entire head and
those big gaping holes or where the
tusks would have come out of they did
remove the tusks we do remove ivory and
if an animal does die over here that's
quite cool don't you think
very cool it's the same
ah no Thomas you're wondering what would
you do if you were to find an elephant
tusks on the ground I think it depends I
probably wouldn't pick it up I would
notify the sabi sand vault team I would
give them a call in where I am and say
we have found an elephant tusks
would you like to collect it would you
like us to hold it in an area for you
but of course you're at risk if you've
caught you you know you're holding
something like that people have
approached these animals for their ivory
and so I probably just leave it in the
bush and give the location of where it
was to conservation team they would then
come and collect it and I would assume
that they have a big vault or safe of
sorts where they will keep rhino horn
where they will keep elephant tusks if
anything like that is of course farm on
the property and of course if they do
catch poachers and they confiscate horns
from them that's where they'll go
now we're looking at those teeth Fox you
were wondering if the teeth ever fall
out or they just wear it to wear away
completely they actually do fall out
sometimes the elephant's most of the
times in fact the elephant just ends up
swallowing them BlackVue wood as a kid
when you lose your pain your milks teeth
or baby teeth and and then they come out
in the don't or maybe they could come
loose
you know biting down on something hard
one that's at the end of its inevitable
chop I mean doing its troubles it's
smooth and so yeah very lucky and how
many of you found them once before in
the Eastern Cape some elephant teeth
that require couch at home somewhere as
naughty as stole them was amazing right
now something that's really quite fun to
watch is a force elephants that are
about to have a swim and it seems as
though Steve's elephants are very
excited about the water
yes thanks very much Taylor ever
breeding herd of elephants that's about
to surround us and then a whole lot of
them down by the water itself right now
having a drink and there's two very cute
and very playful little babies there
straw head do elephants get jealous of
newborn siblings I've never heard of
them doing that I think they like to
play with each other they might get
quite boisterous but I don't think they
get jealous they enjoy the company we
are surrounded right now by elephants
and now this other female probably the
one with the baby see they're quite
relaxed it's gonna walk right in front
of us now you can see her eyes I could
see her eyes are very soft
she's gonna come as close as she wants
to
she's very relaxed only a meter in front
of my car now it's okay mama
here comes the youngsters just precious
it is absolutely precious and we've got
another one here it's being very
boisterous
and the rest of the herd is about to
come now and this is the smallest member
of the herd and if she's about to come
pass the car they're very excited look
at her oh him I don't know hello
it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay
it's just the most beautiful thing I
think I've ever seen I'm gonna turn
around again and then we can have a look
at them drinking you notice that they
weren't bothered by by us at all they
saw us a long time ago they heard us
they smelt us they walked right past and
the behavior of the babies if the adults
were not relaxed those babies you
wouldn't even see them they'll just
disappear inside the herd Sam I'm not
gonna go too much further I think this
is gonna work are you happy with that
okay let me just move my head what more
can you do then just observe so what our
saying is that if the elephant's who
weren't relaxed they wouldn't have come
as close to us as they did and if they
weren't relaxed the babies would
disappear you wouldn't really notice the
that the communication happened but
you'd see the babies disappear in
amongst the hood and they would form
sort of like a phalanx around them with
the bigger females protecting them and
even though they were relaxed my heart
is can beating it's being surrounded by
elephants like that is such a special
feeling and they've chased Egyptian
geese off the island that little baby is
I think it might be the umbilical cord
actually you say that begs it is keeping
up with mum how beautiful is that it's
more ears than anything else so if that
female was not relaxed you wouldn't see
that yang stet wouldn't be just
running around like that and about to
join the frame is about to open and
you're bout to see all the elephants in
the herd doing their thing absolutely
sensational we come here quite often but
you can never get bored of a sighting
like this of elephants at Chitra damn
absolutely fantastic and what is
happening on the left-hand side folks is
there's an enormous herd of buffalo that
is coming down to drink I don't know
what to do said are we going to look at
elephant are you look at Buffalo let's
look at the Ellie's for a while longer
okay let's go across to the buff they're
emerging down to the water's edge in on
mass to drink this is a fantastic day
they come what would the viewers like to
see elephants buffalo both of them
there's a huge herd of buffalo still
coming food the bushes there they always
drink at least twice a day
yes I'm gonna hold off speaking shortly
we've got the little young elephant on
this side it's busy having a swim just
above my head here look at that little
one isn't it having so much fun oh this
is marvelous just legs everywhere
everywhere the thing goes just legs
good afternoon and welcome ladies and
gentlemen we are at Chiba dam with their
herd of elephants a pod of hippos and an
enormous herd of buffalo that is coming
down to drink please feel free to drop
your comments in below my name is Steve
Falconbridge I'm joined by CBM be on
camera
we've come down in the late afternoon to
try capture some animals at the water's
edge and we have been very fortunate
with not only the small breeding herd
and their young baby that is absolutely
loving the water look at that the eyes
the eyes are open with the complete
excitement coming from Juma in the sabi
sands Chitra dam I have no words folks I
have no words for this is the cutest
thing you'll ever see still got its
umbilical cord attached it's following
mum very closely it has had an
absolutely lovely little swim and the
others behind they're also enjoying a
bit of a swim elephants need to drink a
lot of water every day and there are the
only animals are know of that play like
this they come down to the water to swim
to cool themselves and there's an
enormous enjoyment factor behind it yes
Michelle it is a beautiful beautiful
elephant family and they are drinking
and swimming and having an absolute
whale of a time there they go when you
weigh as much as an elephant being in
water makes them quite buoyant so it's
the first time in their life that they
can feel the weightlessness of their
enormity with the Sun setting in the
background the elephant herd to the
right is slowly going off into the
sunset with the littlest member of the
group right next to mums legs
it is just too cute she will stay close
to Mum for the first most years of her
life she'll stay all kids learn like to
play in water indeed indeed splash
around
it is a marvelous time for them there's
nothing more fun than watching elephant
Maggie this elephant brings me so much
joy - before we went live on this
broadcast we had them actually walk
right next to the car and the youngster
barged it's oldest sibling out the way
so it didn't come as close to us as it
was going to and was really quite
special as the elephants have seemed to
finish their play and finished their
their drink they're going to slowly make
their way off into the vegetation to
continue their seemingly endless feeding
nice and wet and cool for the afternoon
with a smile on its face
they almost look very chuffed don't they
the Roman we are coming to you from the
sabi sands in the greater Kruger
National Park South Africa and that
youngsters trying to suckle they sought
a youngster that is a huge elephant is
trying to suckle and it's being
tolerated what are you doing that's very
interesting it's probably his mom anyway
or her mom looks like a he Wow and mum
looks like she's pregnant so it's
possible that she's lactating do you
because she's got a baby on the way
so in Juma we actually had Chitra damn
in the sabi sands Kruger National Park
northeastern part of South Africa in the
province of Puma Langa and there we get
the elephants as they started to move
over the dam war now before we lose
sight of anything else we're going to go
a little bit on to the left of the dam
where we have an enormous herd of
buffalo that have come down to drink and
the buffalo when they come to drink they
basically drop their almost their
diaphragm you could say and they can
take in about 36 liters
of water in a couple of minutes it's an
enormous amount of water to take in
there they are
nice big breeding herd and they're just
having a look at another vehicle a
vehicle has come into the sighting one
of the the chipra vehicles have come to
have a look at these beautiful dangerous
animals one of the big five and we
always seem to have lion prides
following the buffalo so it's a nice
animal species to follow they are very
easy to follow because of the the mess
that they leave behind and the tracks
Pradeep wants to know if that baby
elephant running is not going to get
tired well mum will keep her pace
exactly where it needs to be to
facilitate that youngster it won't she
won't run as far or go as far as as as
she would with older older older
siblings or older offspring but with the
younger ones she has to match her pace
and the distance she goes to that one's
energy so I hope that answers your
question we still have her on the dam
wall with the youngster which is now
catching up on a little bit of muck from
Mom's belly
from mums mammary gland there she is
right underneath is she suckling no
she's just sheltering underneath mum
basically tell him I'm okay mom I'm
tired we can't run anymore and mum won't
go any further than she needs to just
gently walk with her until they get to
where they need to the trumpet of the
youngster that is trying to climb trying
to climb the hill well while we watch
the last scenes of this youngster very
hard trying to climb up onto the wall
we're going to say goodbye to all of
your viewers on this short broadcast and
thank you for joining us if you'd like
to continue watching we are still live
for another 45 minutes half an hour
so please just Google Safari Live and
follow us and we'll see you later have a
fantastic evening
and you are back with us ladies and
gentlemen I hope you've been enjoying
this little scene unfolding in front of
us a trip to them it is always a very
nice place to come to at this time of
day we're always rewarded with marvelous
scenes and there's nothing quite
majestic as majestic as a herd of
elephant moving across the dam wall am I
trying to get us a bit closer to these
Buffalo said what do you think we've
seen some nice illy shots there let's go
and have a look and see okay well we
gonna quickly go over to Brent who's got
some action here we got cameras up in
the tree and there's actually - I can
see - there might be a few more hyenas
about as well below him so he's taking
up what little remnants of food he had
and he's really just trying to get the
last little meat out of the vertebra
there oh isn't that beautiful and you
can see the hyenas hoping for him to
drop whatever little is left so someone
asked a bit earlier today where that
miners were still around or they'd gone
away as I said they were just sleeping
somewhere close by there's very little
food left on there and what makes hyenas
so incredible that they are able to
survive off the little scraps they do
hunt a lot for themselves but their
patience is is undeniable when it comes
to you oh there's another eye in a key
so now we've got three hyenas there's
one coming in from behind us
and we've got this one right under the
tree lots of ticks all those ticks or
wounds zoom up on the neck there the
wounds battle-scarred hyena hyena coming
in from behind you switch sides gonna
come but too much to your right sins
here we go no the hyena coming in
Oh one shot dropped my head coming right
around the front of the car now okay
look at that
now toon is wondering how do you tell
male and female hyenas apart it
generally you look at their tummies
so the tummies is sort of the easiest
way to tell a male and female up high
you know apart the males is that that's
definitely a female but the male's
stomach sort of graduates upwards in a
sort of straight line while as the
females is a bit more rounded there's a
third out is the third high unit just
walking parts disappeared let's have a
look at hooker Morey up there in the
tree again all quickly across to Steve
yes ladies and gentlemen for the
sensitive viewers we are having
something very special happening right
now can you see those hooves there is a
female Buffalo giving birth arrived now
live live there it is look at that that
is the notice and the feet coming
through and see what the mucus of the
placenta coming out the buffalo herd is
staying very vigilant around this female
unbelievable I've never ever seen
anything like this in my life oh look at
those hooves
sorry that they have the Buffalo moving
in the way there's nothing we can do
about it
good afternoon a very warm welcome to
all of you on this stream please pay
attention we have got a female Buffalo
that is giving birth alive on on the
show happening in real time this is a
cape buffalo and we're not gonna go away
from it my name is Steve Faulconbridge
and we've got saved rom be on camera
please feel free to send your comments
through to the on the chat below let us
know what you think your questions this
is happening the cape buffalo giving
birth right in front of us I've never
ever seen anything quite like this
before she doesn't seem too stressed but
the herd is quite anxious it's quite a
tricky position to be in I'm not sure
how long this is supposed to take but
you can see the hooves in the nose of
that youngster as it's starting to come
out incredible staff ladies and
gentlemen we will have other vehicles in
the sighting so if you do hear vehicles
we do apologize yes Linda Linda she can
do it she can do it yes you can see
their boobs themselves are very
unscratched yes Michelle fantastic stuff
amazing Michelle I'm speechless
I don't really know what to say yes
Paula those are the front feet of the
hooves and the nose you can see other
youngsters jumping around this one seems
to be a little bit late it generally
breed in January so this one's about two
months late I don't know if this is
normal that it's taking so long but you
can see how the other Buffalo are very
interested they know what's going on the
males are standing around in God they
know that they can't move off because
this female will not be able to follow
them for some time and as I said we are
joined by other vehicles in the sighting
so I do
do you hear the other vehicles yes grace
this is unbelievable stuff we are very
lucky indeed the Barbara would like to
know if the baby would be breathing it
doesn't seem like it is I don't know
actually I mean the eyes are still
closed I was watching for some breath I
think maybe it needs to hit the floor
but before to start breathing it the
floor to sort of to stimulate those
lungs absolutely incredible
live focus is happening in real time
said indeed this is a first for me I've
never in my life seen an animal give
birth I've seen an elephant too at the
end of birth but I actually didn't see
the process unfold
so they are the vehicles you probably
hear vehicles moving around is that the
headstone to come out here it comes
ladies gentlemen come on the final push
there we go the hardest part is done
come on man come on man be a good mother
squeeze there we go this is so
incredible ladies and gentlemen so
incredible come on mama
everyone's cheering it we're all
cheering here one final push and we will
see the explosion of fluids as the baby
is ejected out there we go the eyes are
open it has open ladies gentlemen here
it comes final push it is astana to
twitch happy birthday baby Buffalo here
we go ladies and gentlemen oh my word
did you see that and that comes the
placenta now the female will turn around
and lick the baby she'll lick it try and
get it to stand up it needs to stand up
within minutes after birth so as to be
able to follow the herd this is a very
dangerous time for a baby buffalo to be
on the ground predators will come in
they will pick out the easiest and the
quickest to catch and that's why the
Buffalo standing around very very alert
they would be very very aggressive
towards a lion or leopard that decided
to come in here
it's one of the chipra vehicles coming
around obviously this is fantastic
except to see there we can see one of
the Bulls standing over yes telly it is
amazing they know what's going on they
know that she's giving birth it's not
the first youngster in the herd there's
quite a few them but she is a bit late
she's a bit late is the herd they're all
standing by normally they would have
left by now after drinking make their
way art how fantastic was that that was
alive ladies gentlemen I initiate there
you can see she's busy licking her she
will lick the baby get all of that
placental juice and fluid off of her
it's also important because the the
mother will often eat the placenta to
get back those nutrients that she's lost
during the birth I know that must sound
quite disgusting to most of you back
home but his part and past what happens
Archer they do lose a lot of energy in
processes like that and it will benefit
her immensely to be able to clean that
baby and the baby there you can see its
head in the bottom left of the picture
Yussef says it's very fast years I don't
know how long it's supposed to take but
the herd was probably here for about 15
minutes before we came and joined them
it's possible that that baby's nose and
feet were protruding the entire time
very unsure one of the other guards was
watching when he came and said she's
giving birth Melanie would like to know
when will it stand it will stand as soon
as it can merican between 10 and 15
minutes the Yanks will get up on very
unsteady Lakes and it'll have to follow
the herd as it moves away from the water
this is probably gonna be the hardest
few hours of its life but if it makes it
through the night it will only get
better Jason you have goose bumps I
think we all have goose bumps look at
her what a proud mother she is probably
not her first offspring she looks like
she's a few years of age probably enough
her late teens even not late teens but
they
the placenta hanging out of her
unbelievable ladies and gentlemen I
don't want to go any closer for fear of
disturbing them I mean a stay right
where we are I know you're all hoping it
will stand up soon I don't know how many
minutes said if you've seen this before
Zeb thinks this is amazing he's never
seen it before I don't know how many
minutes it'll take but it will stand up
in the next little while not sure how
long but it's just watching and see what
happens
at least we'd like to know how long the
hurdle wait before the leave I don't
know Lisa um it really depends on the
status of this female if this is one of
the lead females the hoddle wait until
she's ready to move if this is one of
the old sort of females that's got no
status anymore she's not really a
important breeding female or herd
matriarch then the herd will maybe just
leave her behind
but are there we go she's trying to get
it to stand up she's trying to get it to
stand up Ravinder would like to know how
far the smell of birth would go honestly
don't know I know a lot of the animals
are sure when they give birth the baby
itself is actually almost completely
free of scent it's another reason why
the the mother licks them but the
afterbirth itself must have some form of
smell will definitely attracts a Mahina
in the night but there's not a breath of
air at the moment it requires a little
bit of air to carry the scent and as we
sitting here it is is as cool
there was no wouldn't whatsoever and
she's a very proud mother look at her
she's smiling for the camera going did
you get that I would like a copy one for
the photo album Kathy would like to if
the hippos would come and investigate I
don't know if they would it's possible
that walk past I mean it's not an
unlikely that that a crocodile might
come up and finally after birth they can
smell meat and stuff on the banks
there's only about maybe 50 60 meters
from the river's edge itself and there
were some crocodiles in there in the
water before
there's a nice decent herd of buffalo
you can see they just know that
something's going down in the hood and
they're very very relaxed and willing to
wait it out I think she's quite a high
ranking female and the herd is very very
willing to allow her to do her thing and
allow the next generation of the
dominance because that youngster if she
is a dominant female will inherit her
mom's status within the herd absolutely
sensational absolutely sensational
shaking it off is it going to try stand
up come on everybody let's give it some
support I think it's trying where where
all the cheerleaders out there come on
young Buffalo Paula would like to know
if there's something wrong with the baby
would they rejected or Tecates they
would probably just leave it behind and
if there's something wrong with it if I
can't get up and follow the hood it will
not be able to survive mom might stay a
day or two if the youngsters deformed or
has something wrong with it
that'll basically stay root is and will
be very quickly taken care of by animals
such as lion hyena and even Leopard
Lynne we don't know if any predators are
directly in the area we do know that
King Ghana was seen in Chitra
Tipler lodge itself this morning which
is just on the other side of the dam
from where we are now and it's possible
that this activity of the buffalo might
attract his attention we are keeping our
eyes very firmly on everywhere where we
can see but there are other vehicles in
the sighting I'm sure if they spotted a
leopard moving in they'd be very quick
to tell us but the Buffalo who would be
very quick to tell that ting Ghana the
male leopard what's to do with himself
and we'll have absolutely nothing to do
with him if he comes anywhere near not
only if
to that newborn he is a threat to a
number of the other calves within the
hood and the ultimate life is dependent
on the big males that are hanging around
just waiting for any form of agnostic
behavior from a predator so folks we
gonna say good night to you from this
medium thank you for joining us if you'd
like to continue watching please Google
Safari live we are still on air for
another 15 minutes
we're going to stay here see if this
youngster managed to stand so for all
your questions or comments I thank you
have a fantastic evening the hippos are
shouting that is getting to their time
of night when they are went in to emerge
from the waters for feeding and look at
that Buffalo how marvelous is this
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to all
our regular interview internet viewers
we're all cheering for this Buffalo to
stand I wonder how long it would take
the mother is very very excited to
welcome the new member to the herd what
a beautiful mother she is and how well
she did in that childbirth here we go
it's trying with the front legs
okay so seeing as I'm stealing all the
action and the show let's go for a quick
update to Brent and hookah money Oh her
camera is still munching on the remnants
of that foodie carcass not much left so
it's unlikely he's gonna be here
tomorrow he'll probably be out on the
move patrolling his recently gotten
territory and I'm the interesting to see
if a mint in Ghana eventually ever do
come to blows but incredible to see a
live Buffalo birth with Steve it is
absolutely amazing isn't that exciting a
live Buffalo birth very very cool not
something you see every day so I won't
done Steve all right place at the right
time we're gonna search at with Herkimer
reefer but longer I think he might come
down the tree in the next little bit so
we're gonna keep watching him and let's
have a look and he's almost nothing left
on that carcass at the moment
okay he's definitely not oops where the
hyenas he's just dropped it he's going
down quickly my enas might come rushing
in
yeah the hyenas are running in oh dear
Oh Komori
that wasn't very clever oh happy hyena
tail up chasing off the leopard he goes
he's in front of us through there okay
he stopped now there we go wasn't that
exciting I mean it didn't look like
anything exciting was going to happen
here and Steve had all the action but
the hyenas definitely came in at the
right time as he lost concentration
slightly and dropped that vertebrae now
I want to make sure we don't use them
because I have to say I think he's going
to move now and and in this low light
you can lose a leopard in a few seconds
here we go just have a quick look at the
hyena munching crunch crunch Wow there
was almost nothing left to be honest to
say he didn't lose too much quickly back
across to Steve this youngster is trying
this gentleman in here your support from
afar the front legs have tried the back
links have tried now he just needs to
get them at the same time mom is being
very patient and very accommodating to
this new addition she's giving him it's
a proper lick all over we don't want to
go any closer they want to disturb them
in any way not only is that young
Buffalo not ever seen a car before it's
never seen grass before never seen
anything before now it is surrounded by
family it is a new day for it even
though it is night coming in tonight I
don't think it knows quite what is going
on and it is the temperatures have
dropped a little bit
it's possible that it's a little bit
cold because it's so wet hello Aidan age
six here we go you would like to know if
the baby could hurt its head on the
drops of a grounded it is very possible
but these animals have been breathing
like this for many many many years and
so if it did influence then they would
change their ways so what often happens
is the fall to the ground actually they
fall kind of sideways and their land
with the legs because their legs come at
the same time as the head they kind of
land on those front legs that kind of
hits the lungs between the front legs
and that almost stimulates them to take
a kick the gospel air here we go mom's
helping it up come on there we go little
one it's very shaky
it's very shaky on its legs look at the
umbilical cord I have absolutely no
words what a proud mama gorgeous baby
that is come on take a few more steps
forward I absolutely love my job this is
this is terrible way to spend the
afternoon
SIB said to me when it came out he wants
a very interesting job today because he
hasn't had an interesting Drive in a few
days and so I said don't worry good
vibes we'll get one and lo and behold we
had one of the cutest and four bumps
there he goes one of the cutest elephant
sightings with the young babies and now
we've got a live Buffalo birth court on
safari life isn't that just the most
incredible thing that is I think the
most incredible thing I've ever seen the
live birth waiting to get it - to stand
up everyone's a friend sitting on the
edge of their seat we've got leopards
and hyenas on the other end of the phone
and yet we want to watch a baby buffalo
don't we yes we do
you don't get to see this every day
folks in my 10 years in the bush I have
never seen this before we are very very
lucky right attainment rights a time and
right place is all it is
young Buffalo is still struggling the
rest of the herd is slowly starting to
bed down get the feeling they might have
taken the cue from this mum and are
going to just relax a little bit take
their time wait for the morning before
moving off there you can see them
gay folks are from us to the side we got
the baby he did stand up are we gonna go
over to branches got some action welcome
Ori is walking let's go see where is off
to my ears just popped out into the road
unfortunately fast he's heading in the
wrong direction I'm sorry I've just got
a car behind me so I just need to make
sure they can see him as well
that he's coming back
that's good of you I mean a good smell
good scent Mach maybe we'll get lucky
and he'll give us a a little core oh he
is a beautiful boy
he's definitely setting up shop now he
wouldn't take that much time
scent-marking what not if he didn't feel
comfortable in this area
I love it when male leopards do that put
their head into the trees give me a good
sniff before scent-marking
I get let's move again think you might
go for a drink at the pan
he's just going down to the water just
behind this this pushup
well it seems like Steve has got lots
and lots of babies today yes we do just
had the little baby hippo out the water
has gone back in Beck's wants to know
what are we doing to her today because
there's lots of babies and there's
another one about to emerge just here on
the left looks like that youngster is
about to come out just being spoken to
hang on a second standing about our last
I heard is his mobile towards the
boundary but that's all I could hear but
his scent marking and moving towards
Gary okay so the hippo is being shy has
gone back into the water seems like we
have been having an amazing afternoon
for babies and the like and how
marvelous is that marvelous is that well
we're gonna start carrying on we're
gonna move back to get back to camp
because what else could we see on this
evening's activity Thank You chipper for
once again providing sever myself with
some magical magical stuff this is
exactly where we came to or my interview
drive and again it is full of wonders
and from myself and sever I think that's
might be I lost a little bit we're gonna
go up to Taylor and she's gonna say
goodnight herself well got no good
updates for you no tracks of shedule a
young female leopard coming out of
anywhere so good news means that she's
probably around here in the bush some
way so we will come back and check first
thing tomorrow morning
have a little look I'll be on bush walk
though and that's well that's the plan
we'll see what we can find and try it
all again but anyways off you go across
the brains his catch is having another
drink
knew as he had a quick little drink at
the pan and now I sort of trying to
decide which way to go next
I'm hoping he heads sort of northeast
deeper into Juma and a not south way
from Jima and we're very very close to
the boundary no more than about 60
meters and say really hoping that he
decides to not head south at all I'm
just listening now he'll probably not
move too far before resting up at the
moment and with that full belly you
probably will sleep a little here we go
I was hoping you'd give us a little saw
proclaiming territory and I'm pretty
sure of tanana's at chitwa chitwa you'll
hear that from
and he'll definitely yeah how come we're
recording and good news again he's
heading deeper into Schumer he's not
heading towards the boundary anymore
isn't that exciting
that's very good news unfortunately is
just passing behind a vehicle damage
cannot see where he's moving when he's
very very close to the cars and he's not
as relaxed as the male yepit's around
the vehicles so I'm not gonna move the
car just yet I'm just wait till I can
see that he's far enough where he is oh
yeah hold on
looks like he might take a walk down
towards treehouse waterhole oh he's
right behind me he popped up right
behind me I'm gonna have to wait for him
to parts where is he since is he got
enough okay thanks
changed his mind decided to walk right
past the cart even while I was moving
again well it's nearly the end of the
Safari I'm gonna try to get you one last
view of the Magnificent automotive as he
walks down and towards treehouse Dam so
we got a good idea about where to start
looking for him
bright and early tomorrow morning oh
here he is
we're gonna let him disappear around the
corner on his way to treehouse waterhole
hopefully we'll have luck with him
tomorrow morning while he continues on
his territorial takeover of jummah so
from all of us here at safari live Bhan
we and see you in the morning